ladies and gentlemen ron desantis has
won
he has gotten critical race theory
banned in florida schools though they
didn't explicitly say critical race
theory
they have banned core tenets of the
reactionary
racist ideology that masquerades as
academic theory called
critical race theory many other states
have done something similar
and this leads to a very interesting
conversation around free speech
around whether or not kids should be
taught certain things and of course the
leftists
the woke try to say we're just teaching
kids about the theory but actually no
they're telling the theory is true and
correct
there's a big difference and it isn't
it's a cult-like racist ideology
and they're trying to hide behind
science to make these things
a reality in reality it's a non-theistic
religion
wokeness intersectionality critical race
theory critical theory in general
or as some people call it cultural
marxism so it's a friday night we're
going to be chilling
and talking about political catholicism
or just
christianity in the united states the
moral frameworks things we have to talk
we talk about that quite a bit sometimes
and cultural marxism and i think one of
the core components
of the cr of the culture war right now
is that wokeness
critical race theorists
intersectionality feminists whatever you
want to call it
social justice warriors have an
absolutely different
moral framework perhaps they don't have
one at all and the united states was
founded upon whether liberals like it or
not
a judeo-christian moral framework
joining us to talk about that today is
saurabh amari author of the unbroken
thread
thank you thanks for having me do you
want to just do a quick introduction for
who you are
yeah sure so uh in my day job i'm the
op-ed editor of the new york post
and on the side i write books and most
recently
um i wrote this book the unbroken thread
discovering the wisdom of tradition
in an age of chaos which is a book i
wrote for my
four-year-old son although when i
started writing the book he was two
right on we also have sheamus of freedom
tunes yes i'm here actually i wasn't
planning on doing the show i don't think
we had me slated for tonight but
we got into this really interesting
conversation and all decided that we
should continue it on air so i'm happy
to be here i think this is a really
interesting show
fridays are pretty conversational and
you know we're we're planning on
discussing
cultural marxism critical race theory
and the old the
the more traditional moral framework
which is christian values
and seamus is a perfect person to join
that conversation thank you we also have
ian yeah i'm really excited about this i
listen to a lot of graham hancock's work
he's an archaeologist and talks a lot
about ancient uh history and cultures
and about looking back to remember
you know a lot of the the wisdom that
we've lost over the ages i think it's
such an important conversation
and now but graham hancock believes that
there were advanced civilizations
in pre-history correct um i think he
thinks that they're that they're
it is it is highly likely i don't think
i don't know if he's ever found any
proof of it
i think he's actually making a great
case for lost wisdom by thinking that
you know
well there's a there's i watched a video
of this guy who could move like 200 town
stone
200 pound stones 200 ton stones
by digging a hole under one side and
then bouncing it back and forth
using its own weight against it so
that's you know and and using sand to
push things you know
lowering and like vibration they used to
have these temples where they'd go in
and they'd like strike the key of a in
one area of the temple and the entire
temple would start to vibrate
you know your bones are made of this you
can move very heavy rocks very heavy
objects by vibrating
and now science is developing acoustic
levitation so we're seeing like it's
like almost like we're rediscovering
not i mean i think we have a more
powerful power source than we've ever
had with like fusion and nuclear power i
don't
i don't see any evidence that we've ever
had that amount of energy before but it
seems like we're like
you know recursing technology and that's
what ian will bring to this conversation
about theocracy and religion and
cultural marxism we also have lydia
pushing all the buttons i think it's
will be really fun conversation tonight
i am lydia and the reason the camera
switched smoothly
here's tim before we get started head
over to timcast.com
click that beautiful members only button
and you can become
a member at tim cast which gives you
access to the members only area with a
bunch of really amazing
members only segments it's a huge
library how many pages do we have we
have over eight there's probably way
more
tons of full podcast episodes available
if you are a member
but when you become a member the money
you are paying into teamcast.com is
allowing us to hire journalists to
expand the operation the new website and
the newsroom will be launching hopefully
in the next week or two
and we're going to take this operation
to the sky baby we're i want to have
five journalists working in the newsroom
within the next couple of weeks
i want to have 50 by the next year or so
and i want to actually
start cranking out fact checking the
fact checkers and all the fake fact
checks
and actually doing the ground work on
journalism producing documentaries
producing podcasts that's why we got to
get as many members as possible so with
your support we will do that
and uh let's just jump into the
conversation so um
so yeah why should we have an
authoritarian theocracy i'm kidding
yeah but uh so uh today we saw critical
race theory was trending
and one of the things that really
worries me the most about
whatever this is right i think i
actually think critical race theory is
the wrong way to describe it
we are giving the battlefield to the
left by using their terminology
this battle this culture war has been
going on for a very very long time
and you can say the first modern battle
in the culture war
was gamergate then we see you know
movies video games
comic gate etc where you started to see
this
critical theory whatever you want to
call it some people call it cultural
marxism i think that's a bigger umbrella
term a better umbrella term for a lot of
what it is wokeness is an easy way to
explain it colloquially
but when we talk about critical race
theory it's easily masked
by the woke they just say oh it's just
an academic theory and you're
overthinking things
and we shouldn't ban academics for
children but what's happening is
critical race theory is a core component
it's just the racial component of
critical theory which is
quite literally an advance on um or i
should say developed off of
karl marx's thinking and the frankfurt
school i don't want to get too jargony
but it essentially is a totally
different moral framework from
christianity in the united states
uh and as mostly as my opinions but you
guys can feel you know feel free to
chime in
it's built on a christian framework
christian moral framework
you look at what ben franklin what ben
franklin said about
it's better that 100 guilty persons
escaped than one innocent suffer which
was
just taking from blackstone's
formulation it is better that ten guilty
persons escaped than one innocent suffer
which was just taking from the stories
of sodom
or sodom and gomorrah which i believe he
quite literally said
so we we end up with a society where you
have a lot of secular
liberals atheists etc who are living by
this moral framework they don't
understand it though
you know over time we've moved away from
the more
i guess societally enforced you know
um i don't want to call it theocracy
but societally enforced religious views
or faith and
understanding why we have these these
moral frameworks
by losing that something else comes in
these woke people believe there is no
truth but power and therefore they are
entitled to lie cheat and steal to get
whatever they want
until they gain power so i'm curious
your thoughts you wrote and
you can talk about your book and explain
to us what your thoughts are i think you
called it political catholicism but uh
yeah
sure no i mean i think that's right that
the fact that uh they're moving in to me
um shows is proof that there was never
gonna be any kind of a neutral public
square
that our societies will one way or
another always enshrine some orthodoxy
some authoritative view of what it means
to live a good life
some account of the highest goods of
human life what is what's the purpose of
living
one way or another a society will
enshrine that and for a long time the
society had a
as you said a kind of christian i would
say kind of a a protestant establishment
a protestant consensus and then in the
you know
much of the 20th century catholics and
jews were added to the picture
we started using terms like
judeo-christian and that was the
consensus
and but a certain element of liberal
ideology which i think this this
our society is ultimately a liberal
civilization has this tendency to be
very suspicious
of of orthodoxies of uh uh
you know attempts to enshrine
um ultimate meaning in the public square
and so it chipped away at those
culturally politically over a long time
and we see that
in the vacuum that was created the wokes
moved in
right so and now they're moving very
quickly every element of
national life you know corporate uh
businesses
you know universities almost certainly
obviously but now k through 12 education
there's not a not a one dimension of
american life where you can escape it
so to me that just shows neutrality is
over and it was always an illusion there
was always going to be some
account of what it means to be happy
what it means to be good what it means
to be
exactly fully free the woke the whatever
their you know they call themselves or
whatever it is they need people to
believe there is no conflict
they need people to believe we're just
teaching about slavery
we're just teaching history no i mean
they're quite literally fabricating with
the 1619 project
it is a a i i would i would argue it's a
different moral framework but i think
it's just a lack thereof
it's no it is it's it's it's a it is
as these things often are it's a kind of
bastardized christianity i think
you said that tim so for example it has
an element of original sin
but the original sin in in biblical
religion
is something we all inherit and so and
you have to
you know seek redemption through faith
and so forth
but the opportunity for redemption is
open to everyone and everyone is equally
fallen
except the blessed virgin mary um
um but but so now we have the concept of
original sin but it's sprinkled across
different groups depending on your
skin color you are you know forever
tainted by racial sin and have to spend
your life trying to expiate this with
racial sin
and and if you're a minority or you know
fit whatever intersectional boxes the
more the better like trans disabled
black blah blah blah
exactly then you're sort of part of a
holy class you're sort of
uh you know you're unless you're an
apostate unless you are say
john mcquarter or something like that
well i think this is interesting
because so you were sort of suggesting
that this this wokeness leftism critical
race theory
any of these similar types of thought
are
a moral system in it of themselves and
you're sort of alluding to them being a
lack of
moral system i think what it is is a
moral system without any virtue or any
emphasis put on virtue
and so it can be very confusing to suss
out exactly exactly what it is
and i think you're also right that it
was impossible for there to be any kind
of neutrality
ultimately what the government has to
have is some kind of definition of what
a human being is because you can't
govern something without reference to
what that thing is yeah and so
if humans are created in the image and
likeness of god and the government
believes that it's going to govern a
certain way
if human beings are just blobs of
organic material that happen to have
amassed consciousness
through some information processing at
the level of the brain and there's
nothing inherently value about us
metaphysically
the government's going to govern in a
very different way this is actually
really interesting because
i think we had a conversation about
aliens on on this show maybe a few
months ago
would would the constitution protect the
rights of an alien
if like if like an alien spaceship
landed on earth and these you know
little grey men came out
would they have free speech right so
they have constitutional rights and you
know typically when we talk about this
people like well of course i mean
they're you presumably people and it's
like okay well if it's a different
entirely different species of being then
why do not dolphins or elephants have
constitutional rights
in which case there there is a presumed
definition of who the law applies to
and it's a human being yeah and i would
also say too when people get into
discussion on aliens obviously
it gets extremely theoretical but the
question is are we talking about a
creature which has free will because
people will say things like intelligent
life well how are we defining
intelligence i think ultimately it's
it does this have free will does it have
a soul so to speak or a rational soul
well you know what else is our people
as corporations according to our
government legally and you want to talk
about modern day religion
we're living in it the corporate
corporatocracy maybe that's what this
should be a corporatocracy not a
theocracy
yeah it's interesting you know and you
were sort of talking about this but how
a lot of this intersectional stuff is
really just a corporate religion too it
helps them because
you can look the other way on how
they're abusing their workers as long as
they're giving money to the right causes
and promoting wokeness
you know they all they all change their
twitter bio picture to a rainbow flag
this month so
i guess they're nice and progressive we
don't have to worry about anything
they're doing but yeah i think it's
interesting that that um
wokeness you can kind of trace its birth
i mean
gamergate is interesting but that it
came after occupy wall street
i actually it was it was it was at
occupy it was well no but the thing was
like occupy was making i i think now at
the time as a conservative i was like oh
these crazy leftists but yeah in fact
after the
i but after after what
what uh kind of big finance did with a
great recession
in fact those demands weren't now in
retrospect i think weren't so crazy
because
the the idea that you would privatize
all the gains but then socialize the
risk onto people
that's that's outrageous and that was
crazy but that
movement didn't work and what instead it
turned to is instead of a kind of
class-based
movement having to do with legitimate
economic
is an overweening corporate power in
this country it's shifted to
wokism which is really really easy for
for corporations to accommodate
i actually think that was intentional
during occupy wall street during the
first week or so
actually i know a lot of people are like
where's luke at we we demand
luke no luke i puke so uh our friend
he's a he's like an ancap libertarian on
a luke whatever you describe himself as
uh we met during occupy wall street and
he's he's libertarian right
and i was very libertarian left but we
both met during occupy wall street in
new york
there were conservatives down there
sitting in with on you know sitting down
holding up the american flag during
occupy wall street it was very much just
a general populist movement
complaining about the one percent the
elites and then something really
interesting happened
a lot of conservatives came out against
it and there were conservatives there so
that was you know for me i was kind of
surprised
i actually interviewed some an older
couple and then the woke came in
all of a sudden the conversations around
wealth inequality turned into racial
inequality
all of a sudden when you started making
demands about the big banks stealing
from the working class they said you're
white shut up
and then immediately conservatives and
libertarians started leaving not wanting
to pardon this probably not wanting to
sleep in a park probably
that's fascinating i didn't know that
and then we started seeing the rise of
the i am the 47
movement which to me was also very
strange why were a bunch of people
deciding to be opposed
to a popular economic populist movement
i mean i think bannon just the other day
said tax the rich you know
yeah today he said yeah yeah so so to me
i was kind of like
i was like oh i totally understood what
they were saying but the people who
initially came down and were protesting
the establishment the elites
ultimately what i ended up experiencing
i went to the deplorable
when when donald trump gets elected and
i'm there i'm like wow it's a bunch of
conservatives you know i don't know
anybody i know who some of these people
are
and then all of a sudden some people
come to me like hey tim we're big fans
and i was like oh really i didn't
realize trump supporters you know like
watched my
my live streams and my youtube channel
and they were like no no we were down at
occupy wall street
and i was like and your trump supporters
oh yeah yeah yeah like screw the
establishments through hillary clinton
trump's the one who's gonna knock that
all down
so what happens is wokeness shattered
the the economic populace moving after
2008. and now we've been entrenched in
that battle where i think we are very
much distracted by it the problem is
these these they saw an opportunity to
move in they woke they saw a grievance
and if they saw an opportunity to
manipulate and i think most these
corporations saw an opportunity to as
well
yeah if you shift this to this kind of
stuff
um you know as my friend christopher
caldwell says
um where he says uh you know in in
various realms of life whether it's
public corporations or or
or government or they will just say like
well you know we've done nothing for the
working class we've done nothing for the
working poor
but you know what the new ceo is is uh
is a trans woman and you know so it it's
just
you shift power within elites according
to like hierarchies of
intersectionality without actually
shifting economic justice
right right one one iota now uh oprah
winfrey
is oppressed and a homeless white
veteran and you know in a wheelchair is
the oppressor and his his privilege is
more dangerous because he doesn't
recognize it yeah
um i think that i mean everything you're
saying rings true and also there was
this period of time
i'd say right after the occupy movement
and this was really all post
financial crisis right after 2008 your
ordinary person many people were
upside down in mortgages and what
happened well the banks got
bailed out and so on the right and left
you saw the rise of these populist
movements and you had occupy wall street
which was generally considered to be
more left-leaning
and you had the tea party which was
generally considered to be more
right-leaning
and i think the media in the
establishment were terrified of people
realizing just how much overlap there
was between
those two groups because then you could
actually have the left and right working
together to pursue some kind of economic
justice
but that isn't what happened then you
had a revival of these populist
movements
as a result of i would say donald trump
and bernie sanders and then they were
split between those two groups
but i would say for as much as i dislike
bernie sanders i would get along with a
sanders supporter a whole lot better
than i'd get along with the biden
supporter in terms of what their
aspirations are for the country and what
problems they identify and how they view
the political class
yeah i completely agree although sanders
i think in
2020 got absorbed by the woke blob
certainly yeah look and i i have never
uh as i've said never been a fan of
sanders i think i'm sympathetic to
at least in some way the the desires of
his followers i think i agree with them
when they point out certain
problems though i very much disagree
with their solutions however sanders
was very disappointing it was almost
like he just begged the establishment to
take that nomination from him the second
time
he was never very solution based i liked
the guy's fervor
and vehemence but he was always like we
need to rebuild our crumbling
infrastructure and i was like if he says
crumbling in the structure
i'm going to lose my and he would never
say how yeah i never once heard him say
the one percent has all the money that
we need to take and it was also very
much you're right it was it was just
highlighting grievances and he would
talk about democratic socialism and
there would just sort of be this vague
notion of we will do what europe does
this is you know the most frustrating
thing
is the left doesn't understand what the
economy is or what it means
and they assume that by simply having
money people will
be able to do something they were
already able to do
just because if you like you don't need
the money to do it you just need the
movement within an economy to do it
if everyone decided right now to go
spend money you don't need to tax
anybody the economy would just be on
it would explode people would just buy
and spend and the money would be
circulating really quickly
the amount of money is less relevant to
people actually just spending it they
don't understand that the real core of
the economy is the labor within it
not the digital number in a bank account
that's that's what you end up with
though that's what they advocate for i
think
for me i've shifted on economic issues i
you know i used to work for the wall
street journal editorial page and that's
obviously just you know your typical
uh you know the absolute end of all
government is to cut marginal tax rates
and promote growth over time i mean
partly personal experience and partly
you know you see the uh response the
populist response and you're like well
there's something wrong in american
society um where
the way i put it um actually i should
quote tucker carlson where he says
i don't just want growth i want a decent
society
a society where it's just based on
maximizing growth or maximizing
um you know the economic rights of
individuals isn't necessarily a good
society so there are things where as a
conservative i've come around
to the you know at least the diagnosis
maybe the solution sanders and i will
disagree like you said seamus but
for example health care is is
legitimately a problem in this society
like 100 i have like i you know i have a
corporate insurance you know i used to
live in london and we
had our first child there and you know
you look if if he got sick as
and if you're a new parent you right
away take them to the doctor because you
don't know what's going on
um and you know they were treated for
free
um and then we moved back to the united
states again back into a kind of
corporate insurance plan
kid gets something called the human meta
pneumovirus which is not a big deal but
it needs like
one night of monitoring in the hospital
and we get a bill for twenty thousand
dollars of which we were responsible for
like thirty five hundred and i was like
okay well i could give an extra speech
somewhere i can write an extra essay and
it's not a big deal
but how do what kind of middle-class
people deal they don't know
bankrupt they just go bankrupt
profoundly unjust
and this is another area where i agree
with the sanders types in terms of their
diagnosis of the problem i think the
solutions they propose are really bad
because often it's been state
involvement and just lobbying from
health insurance companies
and government overreach that has led to
healthcare becoming such a disaster in
this country
and they'll say things like well we
should have medicare for all yeah
even in europe most of their universal
healthcare systems are not single-payer
like that
and medicare for all would be
unbelievably expensive at a time when
we're already massively in debt
i can't claim to know what the exact
solution is i tend to be in favor of
limited government solutions but
health care is it's such a complicated
mess right now that i can't say one way
or another this is
this is my preferred policy i have some
ideas and i think it would be good for
lower income people for example
i think what we have to do what we
absolutely have to do is reconnect
people to prices
but in a way that allows for people who
are low income
to be treated when they need it i think
most healthcare spending
is not emergency spending so people
really could be shopping around
but instead they go my health insurance
company will pay for it so they don't
look at how much the services cost and
it allows
hospitals to inflate the price of
basically everything they sell which
makes it impossible for poor people to
get treatment
so i uh for a long time was very pro
universal health care
and even up till sort of recently
idealistically i very much like the idea
of universal health care
kind of like how other countries do it
uh there's a basic level of coverage
everyone has access to and then you
supplement with private insurance
and we we do try to save as many people
as possible
however in the united states we have two
really really big
problems which makes me feel like uh
maybe maybe this is not going to work um
the first of which is bernie sanders
saying abolish private health insurance
and immediately i'm like okay no no no
no no one he's like we should have
universal healthcare like everybody else
and then abolish private health
insurance and i'm like yeah no one no
one did that
you can have your own private coverage
on top of you know your standard
universal coverage
but i'll tell you the nail in the coffin
for universal healthcare for me you know
what it is
it was when they announced racial
distribution for vaccinations
and that was a hard stop if critical
race theory wokeness
are the driving forces for how we
implement policy
and it seems to be the case these days
with them flying black lives matter
flags the embassies
the last thing i want to see is them
going okay now we have your life-saving
emergency medical treatment and what's
your race
hold on a second but why won't why
wouldn't private insurance
adopt woke categories that's the
right like if corporations are going in
direction
so i think a lot of times in you know
rightly so i think in some ways
american conservatives or americans in
general are are worried about um
public tyranny and that's important um
but there's also the possibility of
private tyranny 100 you know whether
it's corporate or
what have you and i think in any other
marketplace you might be able to say
well people can shop around and if the
insurance company
decides that they want to discriminate
against white people they can find a
different insurance company but in a
country
where your access to health insurance is
tied basically directly to your
employment
90 something percent of the time that's
just not realistic and so i agree
i also though i would say this one
another reason that i agree that the
solutions in europe can't work
here is a the united states is a
gigantic country so implementing one
federal health
care system for every state seems like a
com like an impossible to win battle
uh also we are the fattest country in
the world
we are unbelievable i don't think that's
true i don't think that's true though
what did mexico overtake us recently
maybe uh i don't think we're the fattest
they got aspartame and coca-cola went
deep into south america in the last like
15 years
you've seen a large explosion of obesity
oh
yes the united states is no longer the
country but i
oh well you know what that's that's a
misconception that's a misconception i'm
glad to have shattered that said it's
not
as if we have a healthy population per
se nauru
tonga samoa kuwait saint kitts and nevis
countries yes st lucia kiribati
palau micronesia and tuvalu so thanks
for calling that
sounds like per capita they're doing the
measurement spy like america is a fat
country though you are correct oh wait
yeah so
yes so america's a bad country i'm
actually glad you called that out
because i don't want to
spread any misinformation but at the
same time we are a very unhealthy
country we basically eat garbage and
people see the time to take care of
themselves
as being when they're at the hospital
and really it should be when you're
going to get something to eat
this is what i'm talking about the sugar
industry is so involved in our
government it's disgusting
michelle obama had this let's move
campaign when they first got into office
and it was about
let's kick sugar out of our diet the
sugar industries
it was that was about in the beginning
and then so the sugar industry got
involved hey michelle
let's make this an exercise campaign
instead so she did
sugar industry still involved it's like
having big heroin or big cocaine
in your government and i wonder how
connected the insurance companies and
the sugar companies are
making you sick and then making you pay
to get healthy again bro
we do have big heroine in government the
doctors are giving
opioids like crazy it's creating a
pandemic it's destroying this country
it is like that man that's the other
thing too like when you see how our
health care system is being used in
these unbelievably corrupt ways you'll
see like maybe this isn't just a
question of public versus private
it's also um i think it's just a massive
issue with with virtue as well
i think we can get into this at some
point but no matter what kind of system
you have if people are just looking to
screw each other over and get one up on
the next guy
no sis like nothing's gonna work that's
so that brings me back to we were
talking about moral frameworks religion
and you know and things like that yeah
if people have
no shared value system they don't care
about anybody
you know so i'll throw it to luke right
so our good friend luke who's coming
back soon
he has a video and uh i think it's
called
just keep going you've got nothing to
lose where he basically says
you know new york city this this transit
system millions of people
ride the subways every day and they
never talk to each other
and so one day he decided to just go and
start talking to people and asking him
questions
and then you know it gets a little
conspiratorial or whatever but it's a
good it's a good message in the
beginning
it's a good message we stand next to our
neighbors every single day and we never
talk
that's true we don't care you know we we
don't care to communicate with them to
learn about their day
when we had smaller communities we had
things bonding us together
but we also had a very a shared moral
framework
people would meet at church that's where
the communications would happen that's
where ideas
were shared we changed the society
we lost those things we lost the town
center we lost the church as the place
for communication
and now people all of a sudden have no
idea who lives next door to them
that's how it is in new york city many
people don't even know who lives
right above them i saw a funny meme and
it was like on the door
and it said like next to the apartment
number and it was like this
this apartment's favorite shoes and it
was bricks and i was like
do you know the name of the person who
lives next to you i know a lot of people
in new york i used to hang out a lot of
different apartments
people never knew who their neighbors
were oh it's some guy he's like a
tech guy or something i don't know his
name we have no connection
and that means when push comes to shove
when a crisis hits people are just
every man for themselves so um i live in
new york i live in manhattan and uh
we do know i think my wife and i know
the people on our floor
but if you think you know no no we do we
know them um
my wife better than i do actually but
but the upstairs and downstairs we don't
um and that yeah i mean this is
why i wrote this book basically i um you
know i have the son
he's he's four years old now he's used
to when i started writing it
and you know i guess i'm just worried
about the kind of man our civilization
will chisel out of him and i think a lot
of it has to do with a wrong
account of freedom um i think we define
freedom
and this is a product of i think uh
maybe the past three four hundred years
i'll blame the enlightenment uh as a
catholic who's
who's bitter about the enlightenment um
i'm glad there's another one
but but you know this this idea that
freedom just means having the maximal
amount of choice
and there's no difference there's no
difference whether you use your freedom
for good or freedom for evil
in this country the founding generation
did understand that they distinguish
between liberty and license
yes so that true freedom in the in the
kind of classical tradition christian
tradition true freedom meant
um doing what you ought to do yeah
exactly
it and it entailed uh accepting limits
it entailed
duty it entailed sacrifice um
responsibility
responsibility the freedom to do the
right thing basically and
you know when you don't in the in the
book i have a chapter on solzhenitsyn
the great russian dissident he
uh obviously was exiled in the united
states after winning the nobel literate
prize for literature he blew the kind of
he exposed much of the world to what was
happening in the gulag system
and he comes to the united states he's
asked to give an address
a commencement address at harvard and
everyone thinks he'll just condemn the
soviet union
of course he hated the soviet union of
course he ate the communist regime but
he spent most of his time
um criticizing the west and what he saw
as
it's that the west had also somehow gone
wrong
that it had been deformed and
specifically he picked on this idea of
that you mentioned that we're all just
out to
um just to get ahead and yeah and one
one
one one one up each other right um
that's that's also less than worthy of
people he said right and entirely and it
breeds its own kinds of tyrannies
private often private tyrannies you know
it's
and there's a certain kind of
libertarian today where you know you say
well
actual freedom of speech where it
matters which means like exposing power
as a journalist
is dying but it's dying at the hands of
private institutions and they'll say
well that's the end of the debate there
are private actors big tech can do
whatever you want to do if you want to
build your own platform go ahead that's
you know okay yeah
and within a narrow libertarian
framework
sure but in terms of is that is that
good for society
i had a conversation with some trump
supporters a couple years ago at one of
mike cernovich's events he does these uh
night for freedom things and this is in
dc and i was talking to these guys and i
said that
i i oppose the use of
physical and coercive force against
people to
to take from them i don't i think that
you know it has to be free exchange
either through a market or through
cooperation
and one of the guys said whoa a coercive
force
and i was like yeah coercive force or
manipulative force and they were like
elaborate on that and i said
like uh defrauding someone tricking
someone into giving up their possessions
in exchange for something else
and these three guys were basically like
no no no no like we disagree with you
if i convince someone of their own free
will to give me something
that was their choice and that's the way
it should be
and i said so you think that like
powerful institutions
can say whatever they want and if it
convinces people to act a certain way or
give up something that's fine coercion
to it to enforce something is fine and
they were like for the most part and i
was like just like how the mainstream
media lies to us every single day
to get people to vote for people who
extract from our economy and destroy our
our country and then they were like
yeah no that's really bad and i'm like
right i don't know how we get past it i
believe in free speech and there's a
very serious challenge then
when you have basically the entirety of
the corporate press
lying every single day in every possible
way
donald trump cleared a protest for a
photo op
and when conservatives came out and said
i think it was uh molly hemingway the
federalist
there was already a plan to clear the
protest to put up secure fencing
it was incidental that trump came out
afterwards they said fake news
the federalist is liars and fake news we
the media dictate what is true
and what happens when the independent ig
report just comes out
oh all that reporting was correct the
conservatives were right the whole time
the mainstream media exists solely to
lie to people
now to me that is fraud but they have a
right to free speech
and so there lies a very very serious
challenge when you start to recognize
what the left has already been doing
exploiting our values and our good will
to destroy a system that ensures people
have a right to speak freely
they call it the paradox of intolerance
they put out this meme yes
where they say you must not tolerate
intolerance otherwise intolerance will
wipe you out
but the funny thing is they're the ones
intolerant they're the ones banning
conservatives and anti-establishment
actors from the internet
meanwhile they're the ones who get away
with whatever they want and it's the
conservatives who keep
letting them do it of course they push
back and say you shouldn't do this
but we still sit here and say look i
understand
basically the entirety every single
media organization was lying about
everything trump did almost all the time
five years of donald trump as a russian
spy
and we just say but our principles
dictate that we allow them to say it
it's interesting i i believe also um
karl popper who they're quoting in the
the tolerance of of intolerance or
yeah he was also a critic a
heavy critic of communism as well but of
course that's not that's not going to be
something that makes its way into
a little viral comic but i think there's
a few things
he wrote a book called the uh the open
society and its enemies and i
i i've always wanted to write a book
called the closed society and it's
friends
it's hilarious um favors some closeness
yeah no i hear it i'm not necessarily
endorsing him i just think it's fun that
they leave this out
i will say this though uh so tim there's
a i mean there's a few things here you
you mentioned these media outlets and
you're right it's really complicated
because on the one hand they do have
freedom of speech on the other hand they
are saying things that we know to be
lies
not necessarily to come down one way or
the other here but i would ask myself
the question are these people who would
be comfortable silencing me
now i'm not saying someone's rights are
based on whether or not they would give
you the same right
your enemies still have rights but i
think we should at least entertain this
discussion
of something being done so for example
if you
lie about and smear a teenage boy
because he's
wearing the wrong kind of hat and it
fits your narrative then there is good
reason for there to be legal penalty
because you've attempted to destroy
somebody's life with bad information and
your job as a journalistic outlet
is to spread the truth you're talking
about eric sandman yes and nick sandman
um but and i also want to say this you
were sort of talking about freedom a
moment ago and the fact that freedom is
really in
uh antiquity in the classical tradition
the freedom to do the right thing
and with that comes this robust
understanding that freedom
and rights are very much duty based the
reason i have a right to own a gun is
because i have a duty to protect myself
and therefore you're not able to prevent
me
from doing the things that i have a duty
to do and it's similar with the freedom
of speech i have a duty to speak
truth when necessary but if i'm
prevented by do it from doing that
i don't think it matters whether it's
the government preventing me or a giant
corporation my right has been violated
it's a very very serious ethical
conundrum um we don't want to take away
the right of free speech because we know
that they would gladly use that power
against us
in which case 100 percent you're
entering war right so think about it
this way i have a right to keep and bear
arms
defend myself and defend the free state
if they start using their right to bear
arms to aggress against me i've read to
defend myself you're entering open
conflict
if i have a right to free speech to
express and defend a free state
and they start using speech to suppress
and oppress you're entering conflict
but we don't take away people's rights
we just enter that conflict and try and
combat those ideas
the challenge becomes when you are
losing
i mean the two points i would say first
of all i mean
one of the my my big battles within
conservatism
and i famously picked a fight with david
french a couple years ago
but one of my big battles within
conservatism is this tendency to say
you know um if we use power god forbid
they'll use it against us and i always
say they are using it against
us right and no movement there's no
movement that should
that should say our goal is to not use
power
but why are you then a political
movement you are in politics to exercise
power towards some
substantive vision of what is a good
society what do what do i want to do
if i just come in and say well here
because we don't want to use power
that's obviously an invitation
yeah with every opportunity they didn't
do it yeah well some do
so it's it's an interesting paradox
because you have the left which is
entirely power based i mean that's how
they analyze everything and it seems to
be all they want
and then on the right you have people
who just don't want to go anywhere near
any kind of political power because they
view it as inherently corrupting and
it's true that that power does corrupt
so you have to be careful with it and we
don't want to
ignore that but you're also right that
they're using this against us and we
have to do something to defend ourselves
and look the point of having a political
movement is wanting to change something
about society and political power is the
vehicle for doing that
and then on the speech point i would say
just because i'm not a free speech
absolutist actually
um um that that there is a kind of
retconning going on where people look at
the founding
and they impose a basically a post-war
consensus on speech
and they retcon it into the classic in
the into the founding era
the founding era the founders were
would have been appalled by the idea
that there was a free speech right
to you know teach kids about
transgenderism
it just would not have because that's
that's they had a sense of obscenity
right yes that's absolutely right
obscenity who had obscenity laws in the
united states but
you had them in the colonies before
there was a republic there were common
law
centrelias and then we had federal
obscenity laws after the republic
um so the founders were not these kinds
of reason magazine libertarians
we had we had we had blasphemy laws
um you know into the 19th century you
know you had
blasphemy upheld uh as a kind of common
law charge
so um if you're not a free speech
absolutist
then you think okay well there has to be
some public authority
to regulate the abuses of of the kinds
of things we're talking about like
uh you know big tech or or media i think
and in this sense i think it's a battle
line where
uh you know people like me are often
called authoritarians but i'm like well
yeah but the vision the libertarian
vision you have is literally a kind of a
50 60 year old fantasy it is not it does
not have even roots in the fountains i
think we made tremendous improvements
uh in terms of free speech and expanding
the ability to speak
uh i think there were a lot of obscenity
laws were
were dumb but i would say a lot i think
the issue is
the system itself is now being exploited
free speech for me but not for thee
they'll uh you know put the communist
red salute in a children's cartoon on
nickelodeon with a drag performance
but then if you tell a journalist learn
to code as a joke they ban you
yeah so quite literally there is no free
speech in this world
for those who are anti-establishment or
conservative or even
just not woke but the woke have all the
free speech in the world
while claiming freeze which is bad and
therein lies
it makes me think about like a bunch of
people hanging out in a public space and
then
talking and then one guy johnny starts
to sorry johnny if you're out there uh
starts to starts to make a lot of noise
and be disruptive and then everyone's
like stop stop stop and then a couple
minutes go by and he does it again
and again and then you're like you know
you do that again we're gonna throw you
out by force and he's like but i have
the right to do this
well i i don't i don't agree with that i
mean what's happening is
a conservative will go on to twitter and
make a comment about
transgenderism and get instantly banned
for simply having an opinion
not even directly look it's not just an
opinion for stating facts
said okay dude the zoo be the rapper
talking to someone on twitter responded
with okay dude not a genderism just
quite literally as a passive okay
whatever dude
god got a suspension for it the the the
the amount of speech that exists
on the in the cultural right according
to the whims of the cultural left
is zero it's shut your mouth you don't
get any free speech
but thank you for extending us that
opportunity that's what i'm saying so
the second part of what i was saying is
like
then the government so eventually you
throw johnny out he comes back he's like
i'm not the government comes in and says
you can't
stop him from being disruptive and
that's what it feels like this
this this government forcing of us to
to listen to this bizarre
i don't know what you want to call it
twisting of faith or twisting of
morality
how are they how are they forcing us to
listen to like you can't say
you can't tell a transgender man that
he's a woman on twitter that's a
corporation that's not the government
well corporations but that it's
i think the way to to deal with that is
uh first of all reform this law section
230 which
um you know we at the new york post if i
publish
libel um in our pages
our publisher you know god forbid can
get uh
civilly held liable ensued um but
in the 1990s before there was ever a
twitter before there was a facebook
congress enacted a law called the
communication decency act
of 1996 where it gave these platforms
um at the time there were like internet
bulletin boards that were completely
nascent so no one had
any idea that would become so big the
right to act like publishers meaning to
censor
kind of violent threats you know truly
kind of prurient content child
pornography or what have you
and nevertheless not be subject to a
publisher's
traditional publisher's liability that's
the provision
that twitter and facebook use where they
act like publishers
but they don't but if you publish libel
on their con website they
they cannot be held civilly liable the
law actually extends
rather uniquely to literally any web
service so
interestingly i think you actually have
an argument for not being able to see
the new york times
i'd love the new york times to just cite
section 230 as a legal defense because
it would probably work
230 just says a online web service it
doesn't define
social media or anything and so
there's no distinction between publisher
or platform none whatsoever
there's interesting conundrums in that
regard then because i brought this up
with wikipedia
wikipedia uses the 230 shield where they
say
you can't sue us for what a wikipedia
article says about you because it was
written by
users not us however the published
page on wikipedia was not written by
users
it is an amalgam of a bunch of different
comments from a bunch of different
people
but then formatted and published by
wikipedia with that with a banner that
reads
from wikipedia the free encyclopedia
considering that they have now claimed
publisher
of this article and you don't see the
user's name or picture or the link
that's i think wikipedia is the biggest
grounds for a lawsuit in terms of libel
and the clearest case is
to me is is twitter though because
twitter has now it has its own editorial
voice somehow where
if you look at the trending material
some like hack has written something
like
people are talking about governor
desantis
banning the teaching about racism
obviously and
in this kind of completely new york
times stupid live framing
but um that you that is no longer just
like a neutral platform
whereas its own world view yes yes so
then okay then you should be sued
you could sue twitter for what they
write
so when for instance twitter said that
james o'keefe was operating multiple
accounts
james o'keefe sue's twitter saying that
was a false statement of fact oh sure no
but i'm saying that the fact that they
act like that the fact that they have
their own editorial voice
just makes it clear that they're no
longer any kind of a just the web
service they're a publisher
and therefore they should be subject to
liability i i think the bigger problem
is times v sullivan
the the higher well i should say it's
time to pull visual event as well as
section 230.
those aren't familiar times v sullivan
created the actual malice standard and
defamation suits
so there has to be a reckless disregard
for the truth or you had to know you
were lying which is actual malice
i think what's happening now that needs
to be challenged
uh what what separates twitter
deciding what is allowed to exist on
their platform in terms of other people
writing things
and the new york times separate you know
deciding what's a lot on their platform
and choosing
and choosing what appears in the front
page twitter through algorithms
and through their rules will remove and
shadow ban conservatives
for the most part they there are
leftists who get banned for sure but
it's a tendency towards banning
conservatives and
it's a very strong tendency so um
what's the difference between that and
the new york times saying we're only
going to allow this to appear on the
front page
money is that is that really it no no
i mean this seriously if twitter says
okay uh sorry you tweeted learn to code
and ian tweeted happy pride
i'm gonna ban you hey guess what the
only thing that appears in the front you
know
on the on the news for everybody is
exactly what ian said and i banned
everybody else
so it's it's this really fascinating
thing where they're like i didn't
choose to put his writing on the front
page i just asked one
million people to write their opinion
and banned all of the opinions i didn't
like
so quite literally exactly what i wanted
appeared on the front page
whereas the new york times says we have
30
i mean the new york times probably has
thousands of contributors who all write
articles and then they say
we looked at all of them and we've
decided this is the one that will go on
the front page
what's the difference the new york times
corporation paid that person
all right here's what i'm saying here's
what i'll do i'll create the tim cast
uh community user board where i'll ask
people to contribute to writing whatever
wild and and cockamamie garbage they
want and we'll put it on the front page
statement of fact boom sue me i'm
protected by section 230.
i think the difference is that the new
york times has a human
choosing it and curating it whereas the
twitter has an algorithm doing it no so
they're kind of like be hiding behind an
algorithm
so so twitter uh uh i i could argue that
i'm willing to bet new york times has
filters for their for their
contributions that come in that
you know stupid things get thrown in the
trash and spam folder right okay well
there you go
i'm sure i'm sure the new york times has
an email account and a gmail account and
they're spam filters and algorithm it
sort of sorts out what doesn't get to go
on the front page i think it's an i
think it's arbitrary
if a human does it or if an algorithm
does it that you built that a human
built if a human built the algorithm to
pick it for you or if you pick it it
doesn't really matter
it shouldn't matter another possibility
is to treat them and this is just as
uh clarence thomas voiced this
possibility
to treat them like common carriers right
like that they're like
um air airlines or telephone providers
or what have you where you
um you know as a as a user you know you
have to use it because
that's how people communicate now and so
um
you know you're an airline blessedly
cannot say
well because of of your worldview
shameless your
terrible views as a catholic like we're
not going to sell you an airline ticket
they can't do that and so likewise a
common carrier social media company
shouldn't be able to do that
one of the things that happens
interestingly on twitter is that
a twitter account uh that
twitter is we'll write something
libelous twitter as an organization is
protected by section 230
but twitter as an organization is the
only one who knows that account belongs
to
so what's happened in the past is that
there will be an account called like you
know ian is dumb
and they'll say you know uh ian wants
punch to go right that's the go-to thing
for absurd statements and then when ian
says
i'm going to sue this person for libel
twitter says
we will not turn over the records of
this user so ian has to sue twitter
first
to figure out who defamed him in the
first place and then twitter blocks it
and files a bunch of
billion with their billion dollar
corporation legal apparatus
shutting your lawsuit down and then
you'll never figure out who actually
defamed you and you can't see them
anyway
we've got a very very serious problem
the mainstream press has been pumping
out trash lies
i'm sure the corporations love a
confused and demoralized population
we have no reasonable means to actually
do journalism
and stop misinformation when big tech
corporations shield defamation
and cnn is propped up by youtube and the
minister of misinformation brian stouter
himself is given preferential access on
his content
yeah i mean i think we need it we need a
regulatory
and then i mean to go to your point tim
about the the press i mean i'm so
so embarrassed for my profession you
know we in
in february 2020 we ran an opinion
column in the post
uh by the china scholar steve mosher
where he
speculated he wasn't he didn't
definitively say but he speculated
that the the virus could be man-made in
origin oh no
and and you know you know obviously it
didn't take much at the time it should
have been so obvious
uh the epicenter of the pandemic happens
to be where the chinese have the only
lab capable of handling corrosive
sl4 yeah this is the only one and so
that's all he said and
and facebook banned our you know
article and the new york post is the
oldest continuously daily
kind of published newspaper in this
country founded by alexander hamilton
new zealand newsguard says your fake
news now oh yeah yeah
of course no it gets even worse we were
talking about this on the after show the
other day
um francis boyle he's the author of the
american implementation
of the biological weapons convention uh
known as the
i believe the um biological weapons and
terrorism act of 1989 it passed
unanimously
and it's basically the rules for what
kind of
meddling with different germs is legal
what's biological warfare
what isn't and at the beginning of the
pandemic he
said that he believed that the
coronavirus was a bioweapon that's how
he defined it and he's the person who
wrote the legislation that is the law of
the land of the united states
and he is referred to as a conspiracy
theorist which is insane to me just
heard a crazy uh new conspiracy theorist
from the sage duncan trussell on joe
rogan's uh
one six six six podcast just recently
that what if some crazy eco-terrorists
went to wuhan
and released it right next to the bio
lab to make us think that it came from
the bio lab
ah it just keeps getting deeper yeah but
that one's that one that one's right
it is a simple it's just a much simpler
explanation to say it was released from
the lab
at this point i would say now that we're
learning that early on scientists
believe it may have been engineered
that kind of changes everything so we
know that and fouchy wasn't telling us
that
yeah he he wasn't too uh for i think
weinstein mentioned that when they were
studying the
the structure of the actual virus that
they were saying it looks like it's been
it's been tampered with so we have we
have a bipartisan elite that so
benefits from from the relationship with
china is so bound up with the idea that
opening up china was a good idea
even though it decimated the middle
class in this country even though it
empowered this vicious horrible
totalitarian regime
but they're so so wedded to this idea
that i think it just cannot be
acceptable
to them that this was a lab leak issue
so it just it embarrasses our entire but
again a bipartisan elite it's not just
it's not just democrats
it's it's kind of the uniparty of the
bushes and the clintons and the obamas
and goldman sachs and blah blah blah we
have a we have a decayed
system right now and i think it's i find
it fascinating that
you know conservatives still refer to
what antifa does as rioting
and i'm like when the moment
conservatives had a riot it was called
an insurrection
yeah it was like the first conservative
riot in you know decades or plus right
it was an insurrection
and even now considers are still like
auntie for riots i'm like i don't know
maybe we maybe that's insurrection
yeah maybe after a year of burning down
buildings and throwing bricks at people
and beating cops and
challenging the authority subverting it
and infiltrating institutions
you can call it subversion at least the
insurrection
whatever i think but it is it is so
state-backed yeah right
the mayors of these blue cities and
governors uh would blue states and blue
blue cities
would kind of wink at them which almost
makes it more of an insurrection right
like when you're flying their flag
at one of your embassies it's almost
like there's an insurrection and they
want i mean people have been thoroughly
intimidated
it's you know when people talk about
them forcing on them the militant wing
of hezbollah and the you know the social
welfare wing it's kind of like that and
at some point it's like
it's a militant winger yeah no of the
left or the democratic party
we created a system that was very
forgiving that
offer up a lot of good will and our
enemies
exploit that and so good people of
principle like i mentioned with free
speech will say
i know they lie about us every single
day to destroy
true freedom and liberty and uh we will
continue to afford them the right to use
these things
while they strip us of those same rights
so how did it get how did it get
here like obviously we had a system of
free speech for 200 years uh leading up
to now
did they and they were like militantly
they would crack down like in world war
ii they had like put people in
internment camps
in the 1800s they would i mean i don't
know we
locked up under wilson or attempted to
be locked up for like protesting world
war ii
we had an office of censorship yeah
silence accelerates victory was the
slogan of the world war ii office of
science
and you've got to wonder at some point
were they right
like is on a bright unbridled free
speech
is it opening us up to being manipulated
from outside powers it seems like
they're
if you're too far in either direction
then you're setting yourself up for
disaster
i'm going to let you in on on a sad
truth ian
liberalism is a luxury of those not in
conflict
uh i've talked about this for years um
that
for instance feminism as we know
intersectional feminism and critical
race theory
is only able to exist because we live in
this beautiful protected bubble that no
one can invade
if we were actually dealing with
international conflict and we were
facing
civilian attrition people were dying and
being killed and cities were being
bombed
you better believe they would lock down
free speech and go nuts arresting random
people
abraham lincoln every he what he tried
to do there's like the legend that he
issued an arrest warrant or wanted to
for a supreme court justice
war you don't have the luxury the people
who are willing to get aggressive
and and and violate principles are the
ones
who who in many instances end up winning
and that's horrifying
so we want to maintain our principles we
want to believe in freedom
but now what we're starting to see in
the u.s is a lot of people and this is
the crazy thing not even the u.s
i was in the uk and some british
conservative activists told me that they
used to be classically liberal and other
fascists
and i'm like get out of here you're not
really a fashion and they were telling
me no but they're full on authoritarians
they think that the only way to combat
the incursion of
marxism and these these insane
ideologies
and this moral corruption with their
society is by force
to in to ensure the protection of your
values
and you know what the united states did
it in world war ii
so so these leftists want to talk about
here are the u-boats storming normandy
those are the real anti-fascists
guess what they really do mean it okay
they were technically anti-fascist in a
sense the anti-fascists by name back
then were communists
but the americans had an office of
censorship we put people in
concentration camps internment camps
what are you going to call them
we literally said yeah you'll look a
certain way so we're going to lock you
up
the united states violated the rights of
so many people to win that war
and the same thing happened in the civil
war but you know what not a single
person i think would say the u.s was the
bad guy the north were the bad guys in
the civil war
not a single well i should say not a
single person obviously
there's the sound the war of northern
aggression yeah there are oh this way
i'll put it this way in modern society
the average person would say the north
were the good guys
when you bring up all of the rights that
were violated that we did had to be done
then you say 1945 internment camps for
the japanese and the suspension of
freedom of speech
and they would say well you know the
nazis were bad we did we had to be done
that's scary to me because it's it's the
reality of war
well i think you can get more nuance
though and say well yeah the north were
the good guys and the allies were the
good guys in world war ii but war crimes
were committed and we should condemn
those so for example
for example the bombings of hiroshima
and nagasaki were horrific war crimes
sherman's
march to the sea just burning down
civilian homes and making warfare on
innocent people
it was believably horrific was that the
first iteration of scorched earth i
think the march to the scene i don't i
don't i
i'm not entirely certain i remember
hearing that but i
don't i think it's been going on for
thousands of years yeah very old
principle
the romans would do it yeah that's right
i mean i want to go back to you you said
something liberalism is a luxury for
for uh when there isn't war or when
there isn't violence
i would also say liberalism itself um
has been a tremendous force for
for violence itself right in the sense
that um
first of all i mean especially in europe
liberalism the rise of liberalism
french revolution right is a classically
liberal revolution
no no no leftism doesn't quite come into
the picture
not certainly not uh like a kind of
economic marxian left
in the late 18th century these were
liberals there were bourgeois liberals
who want to unseat a kind of traditional
authority specifically the church
yes that
raping nuns stripping altars and putting
up like
uh you know a god the goddess of reason
instead of instead of the virgin or or
the cross
changing calendar so liberalism has come
to power it's
because it's been nearly two three
hundred years um
it's got this glow of uh uh sepia tone
that it's
this kind of gentlemanly powdered wig
people who just wanted like rational
discussion but it itself was
an intrusive force in the world and p i
mean a lot of people weren't prepared to
say well here's an ideology
that wants to divorce the individual
from political community from tradition
from
local places and just wants to have the
kind of just a rights
exercising rational individual alone on
his own
to bring that world about involved
tremendous violence
and it continues to be as my friend
patrick deneen argues that wonderful
book
why liberalism failed it's not the case
that it's
we we face a battle between
individualism and statism
or attention between those two the two
grow in tandem
because the more you kind of
individualize the person remove him from
these traditions that guided us over
centuries
and kind of gave you a sense of what's
what the good life is the more you
remove him economically and make him
atomized the more he has to rely on the
state
yeah forces rights to protect those two
forces go in tandem they're not
oppositional forces individualism and
statism
are friends i think there's truth in
that yeah i think excesses of
individualism end up leading to
authoritarianism and collectivism and
part of why i invoked the left when you
were talking about the french revolution
is because this is something i've said
on the show many times
before but it's part of why catholicism
and leftism cannot be reconciled because
like the
intellectual origins and foundings of
leftism
come from this time period we get the
terms left and right from the french
revolution and the purpose of the left
since its inception
has been to oppose traditionalism to
oppose specifically catholicism in the
church
the left side of the national assembly
yeah yes so
one of the pulling up sherman's march to
the sea one of the most horrifying
things
the end of slavery what what was a
contributing factor one of the
contributing factors that led to the
eventual surrender of the confederates
and ultimately to the reconstruction era
and the abolishment abolition of
slavery it was when
wow major general william tecumseh
sherman of the union army
began to march from atlanta burning down
and destroying
industry infrastructure and civilian
property
the operation broke the back of the
confederacy and helped lead to its
eventual surrender
sherman's decision to operate deep
within enemy territory without supply
lines
is considered to be one of the major
campaigns of the war and is considered
to be uh considered by some historians
to be an early example of modern
total war what did they do they
destroyed civilian property
yeah they wiped out people who had who
didn't want to be involved
but you know what the reality of war was
the food they make goes to our enemy
and if we want to end slavery this was
one of the tactics used
and it worked that's really horrifying
isn't it it is horrifying but also i
think there could be a better way
because
every other developed nation ended
slavery without committing similar war
crimes i mean i'm on the side of the
north here but
other countries mostly i believe the
united states is the only developed
country that ended slavery through a
civil war
we're going through some kind of new
iteration fourth or fifth generational
warfare with what's happening in this
country and i think it's fair to say
that
those who believe in freedom and liberty
or classical liberalism these ideas
have probably already lost i know a lot
of people say that and i think james
lindsey isn't something that a fact
there are people like michael malus who
are much more optimistic and say there's
no way we can possibly lose so
mel says that yeah he's very much like
look how stupid these people are how
could anyone be you know blackpilled on
this these people are horribly dumb and
he's got a good point
i like michael mouse a lot dumb people
win all the time wasps are really dumb
too
and lots of them can easily kill a
person and carry on and do it again
so what we end up seeing now is i'll say
it again our embassy's flying the flags
of black lives matter
and of course the rainbow flag the
sacred yes liturgical uh
item that is not to carry crazy that was
important
yeah that one that one very much is the
the centerpiece in many ways of the
modern religion that they have
it's i mean if you question any of their
um views on quote-unquote sexual
freedom that's it that really is the
group you're not allowed to speak out
against
and reality yes it forces you to
this is the most totalitarian aspect of
it it forces you to say that
something that you know is not true
right the fact that uh there are two
sexes yes and gender has this kind of
embodied component that you cannot
overcome
just by willing it or with surgical
mutilation but you have to say that you
know
there are first of all that there are
135 or however many genders
infinite infinite possibly infinite i
mean it's
it's entirely concrete right sex is
entirely concrete there are two possible
roles that a person can have
and your subjective sense of
self-expression doesn't change that at
all
we talked on this we talked about this
in the last year we did and i think it
was on the after show segment but
part of my belief here is that this is
just the inevitable outgrowth of a
contraceptive culture because
once people lose sight of the sexual act
as being procreative it becomes about
pleasure and self-expression
absolutely and so it's not a question of
what am i doing to contribute or create
it's a question of how am i expressing
myself here
and then you become entirely detached
from a reality and you create
millions of different expressions that
in no way shape or form map onto the act
which is occurring
i i think we're referencing i i agree
but i think a lot of it is just
remnants or or um an outbreak from
deconstruction when words become
meaningless
and i think that the the goal is
basically that nothing means anything
ibrahim x kennedy was asked to define
what racism was and he said
racism is racist racism is when
institutions have racist policy
and it's like nope what okay use the
word to define the word yeah what are
you
what are you talking about so when it
comes to gender as well men and women
become
entirely meaningless and that's why
there's a meme where you ask someone to
define the word woman yes
and they they can't now scientifically
it's very simple it's an adult human
female
exactly but then not complicated yeah no
i mean if you look up any academic
journal it says this in
modern mainstream culture it is a ban
worthy offense
to assert something like this let alone
the
zooby said okay dude well and this is
also
this is the point i was making earlier
with these violations of people's
ability to express themselves it's not
as if it's
my opinion versus your opinion and the
conservative penny just happens to not
be allowed on twitter
it's not a conservative opinion that
there is such a thing as a woman
and that women are different from men
like this is a fact the fact that a
woman
is an adult human female is a fact
and yet you're banned for stating it
it's not as if this is one person's
opinion versus another person's opinion
these are concrete realities
well they were but when you have a group
of people who are dominating our
cultural institutions
who are in every major corporation and
advertising network and are making the
rules for social media
then you get governors and politicians
locking you down so you can't go and
talk to people
they wouldn't let people go to church
the only way to get europe to get your
news was through social media
which has filtered out even fact-based
news articles we know to be true
from the likes of the new york post yeah
so the only opinion and news you're
getting is the one
they deemed you're allowed to get
exactly dr fauci he is the science
yes you cannot debunk me i am science
i tweet i said that i tweeted again last
night and felt guilty that i was using
twitter and not mines
like why i keep using twitter i like
twitter i mean i like i like the idea of
twitter
it's it's functional it's big but why
why do we keep using it
i mean it's it's unfortunate but it's
the place where other people are going
to hear you
and they did everything they could i
know why we use twitter because
when uh parlor attempted to launch the
massive companies got together and said
we're not going to allow that
and that's why we're using twitter now
like the next day
you gotta have fun with it right so the
other day i tweeted imagine not thinking
the foo fighters are the greatest band
of all time
everybody was like tim what's wrong with
you how dare you do you actually believe
that i think i liked that tweet actually
uh i i i
i posted i posted a month ago who is the
greatest bet what is the greatest man of
all time and why is it radiohead
the point is i just know that these are
things that people get riled up about
like
your favorite band is of course your
opinion on music is better than everyone
else's
most people have fun with it and they
post things like no my favorite band is
this
but it was funny just how how like
people just erupt and i'm like that's
what twitter is for
see michael malus has it right in that
regard however
i don't completely agree with him when
he points out someone being dumb on
twitter and i'm like dude
a zombie horde can wipe out a
civilization
in every movie we've seen it okay maybe
not really
but if you get these but barbarians can
overcome rome
yes yes seriously yeah anybody or the
french revolution can happen
look anybody who's played like og
og warcraft you just spam from the
barracks a bunch of knights or
grunts and then just keep sending them
non-stop and overwhelm your opponent
that's how zerg became a verb
you basically the zerg are from
starcraft it's this alien like lizard
if you see bat or uh what's the starship
troopers where they fight the bugs
that's the zerg
and they would just make massive amount
of zerglings and then rush the opponent
they're like really weak
so they're just oh i'm being zerged i i
famously have a very um
uh kind of uh quick to block trigger
finger
so i just i i i deal with the zerg the
way the starship troopers i'm like
but what i'm what we mean by this is if
you have
10 million really dumb people and they
show up with bricks and torches
the cops are going to leave the mayors
are going to give them what they want
and the same rational people who don't
do that
lose everything yeah well i mean the
police did get defunded
political violence in this country
worked which is what made that
um when they turned it into a kind of a
911 they call it one
six what what made their response to
that so outrageous is that they had
spent the summer
making it clear that political violence
gets you results
yeah right if you want to defund the
police very good you know
burn down entire neighborhoods
working-class neighborhoods but
conservatives aren't willing to
be insane lunatics who want to hurt
people unfortunately
or moderates yeah if you just have this
extreme sect of people that are kind of
twisting out of their mind and everyone
else is like
i want you guys to sing a moderate riot
they're like some of this but not too
much no i want you to imagine this i
want you to imagine like jordan peterson
and dave rubin angrily marching in their
nice fine suits
with torches no and jordan peterson if
you think i'm not gonna burn your store
down you're absolutely wrong man i've
got this brick for a reason it's going
through your window
hi that's a pretty good impression thank
you but could you imagine dave rubin
like
marching with a bunch of angry people to
cause violence it's
never ever gonna happen and you know
what these companies and these mayors
and these democrats know
they have zero to worry about from
people who challenge their orthodoxy
yeah i don't want a government of
reactionaries
i don't know if they think there's
nothing to worry about though because
they're working very hard to ensure that
people get censored you always see these
op-eds written about large youtube
celebrities who have larger platforms at
this point than these media
conglomerates do or
some of their you know favorite
properties on their
um on their networks have and
you almost always get the feeling that
this is because they want these social
media platforms to step
in and start silencing creators who the
media deems as problematic because again
they're competition
uh but that said yeah i think they
really are afraid they wouldn't be
trying to censor us otherwise no i i i
don't i just i disagree i think of it
like this
if uh the people on january 6 they
engage in that behavior the fbi goes
full force against them
but when you completely demoralize and
[ __ ]
an entire army what do you then do you
humiliate them
and you start to torture and demean and
be right
when when you know china had pows i
can't remember where this was i don't
know if it was like korean war vietnam
or whatever
they would absolutely use manipulative
tactics and try and demoralize and break
them down
so censorship is basically like look
after you've wiped out their navy
you storm the beaches so yeah we've lost
our our navy in this regard we have no
defense for our figurative shores
and the censorship is just them
continuing the the the onslaught as we
were treating
we're we're running back the line is
broken and they're still changing they
call that a route
exactly i think part of the censorship
regime i think oliver bateman made this
point in a great american greatness
essay where he said
it's um it's not really about not
letting the rabble access information
or that's not solely about that it's
also for the elites themselves
to create a bubble in which they're they
don't hear
from what the majority you know normal
people think
right normal people normal people don't
want stupid wars in the middle east
they don't want socialism but they also
don't want like a kind of predatory
capitalism
and they don't want their kids being
taught like they want their kids to
learn about you know the napoleonic wars
and homer and poetry and not to just
sort of endlessly solipsistically
meditate
on their own race and gender they don't
so so normality like sane politics are
possible if you just minimally listen i
think still to ordinary americans
but elites by censorship they actually
just block
themselves off and i think that's very
dangerous because you can't have a
superpower
that whose elites don't actually know
what the f
is going on in reality right well that's
why we're not going to be for much
longer
no i don't think so i don't think so an
elite that says stupid you're like i
mean i i
sometimes i'm like look the chinese in
some sense deserve to inherit the 21st
century
i hate their regime it's a monstrous
regime it puts a million people in camps
whatever
but you know they don't have an
intelligence
agency that does its recruiting by being
like i am a and
you know i have anxiety disorder and i
work for the cia
like you just kind of imagine the
politburo of the of the
chinese communist party or inside the
kremlin like looking at the oh yeah
you're like they must be laughing if
someone i i can imagine someone going to
i guess there's no name for the chinese
intelligence it's called beijing but
imagine you know there's a chinese
national going to beijing and saying
i've got anxiety disorder i'm gender
non-binary and they're like interesting
interesting right this way they put them
in a room
and they put a pry bar in front of it
and weld the doors shut and walk away
like they did other people got sick
they do not tolerate anything that could
be a threat to their system they
literally killed their own citizens for
it right
right and you have to i mean it's just
not a serious power i think
a power whose central intelligence
agency is obsessed
with you know the gender identity issues
of
of the agents it's just partly like the
way our government's set up right now is
if you want to contact and communicate
with like a representative you can't
you can contact their office and like
leave a message for their aid or
something but there's no way to like
talk to
you know rand paul right now if i needed
to if we had like internet video where
like
as your job as a as a congressman is to
sit down and listen to like 20
30 youtube videos a day you know minute
one minute clips or like
uh you know 120 of them a day two hours
you sit there and you listen to people's
suggestions
i could see that yeah but it's still
limited i mean it's very limited because
you can only get 60 people or 100 right
if you're if you're like a mind
meld type thing i don't know man i
i think it's i mean the media is
supposed to do that for the
representatives
the media is supposed to reflect public
opinion in part um but instead what
they've done
is to think of themselves as mediators
between what
power wants to do and this stupid rabble
that they you know is doesn't know
what's good for them and the media's job
is sort of to like massage the messages
of power
to the people rather than reflect it to
power and hold power accountability
the root of the worst mediator is media
what
yeah yeah the mainstream media the
fourth estate
used to be that they were considered to
be almost a co-equal branch of
government they would challenge the
power and regulate it and such
that the people had an opportunity to
challenge the corrupt
not anymore we kind of do like this show
is an example of it because we could
have people on the show that have an
opportunity to express
like unknown opinions and then people
like rand paul will hear it because
people
they watch it and i think one of the
most important things we're doing is
over at timcast.com
because uh i i was i was talking about
this in an earlier video today
you know brian stelter he was on c-span
and people were calling up
c-span and it was hilarious they were
like you are the you are the worst
disinformation
you know outlet cnn is trash you're
liars one guy called him the minister of
misinformation and said at this point
if you do the opposite of what cnn says
you'll probably be better off
so i tell people we can't just be
doing shows where we complain about it
it's a good thing
to spread awareness but you have to do
more than that you have to create
stuff so that's why i wanted to i
reduced by 50
the amount of segments i was producing
every day because i wanted to make the
vlog happen i need more time to do that
i need more time to look through job
applications and expand the business
now we have a vlog which the ninth i
believe it's the ninth episode coming up
tomorrow morning
and here's what i always tell people
we're not we're not there yet we're
building it it's hard we do not have the
resources of these massive corporations
or the privileges that youtube grants
them but in that skate park
when a dude shows up on his bmx and
grinds the grind bar and it's his big
deal has a gadsden flag right there
that means some little kid who watches
that youtube video is going to see the
gadsden flag
and he's not going to know too much
about it but then one day when he's in
school and his teacher says some stupid
critical race bs about the gadsden flag
being racist
he's gonna go what no the castle guys
have one of those they're not racists
they have people of all different types
over there is my teacher lying to me
yeah we need to produce culture talk
about what we're for
and make things so instead of just
complaining with the media lying all the
time
what are we gonna do well we've got some
people coming out we're gonna hire
to do journalism and of course we're not
the only ones doing it but more
people need to we need something
comparable we need
if the fourth estate has been destroyed
we must rebuild
hopefully we're you know considering
we're facing conflict
they'll try and come and shut us down
they'll try and stop us but to be very
very careful about what we talk about
when we do it
on channels like youtube but once we get
the website up and running
we get a bunch of journalists we can say
whatever we want
yeah within reason obviously yeah i tend
to agree with what you're saying here
i believe conservatives need to put more
emphasis on creating culture this is
part of why i do freedom tunes i like to
do these little animated shorts that
are promoting these values i really just
make them because i want to make
something funny but because my values
are
conservative and catholic they'll come
through in the content
but the problem is conservatives
generally scoff at immediate strange
they'll lament the fact that they don't
have enough representation in media
but when someone says they're going into
media they tend to laugh at them
and they definitely won't let their
children pursue a career in media but
the reality is the way the left has
gotten their morality across
is by very passively asserting it in the
background of the things that they
create
or in the foreground but not in an overt
heavy-handed way so they'll just have
characters in their films agree with
certain lifestyle choices that other
characters have made
without beating you over the head with
the fact that the producer thinks that
that's an okay thing to do
they'll have characters talk about how
they have casual sex but it won't be a
driving part of the plot of the film
they'll have characters
discuss abortion in a way that isn't
condemning it or homosexuality
they don't sit there like conservatives
do and say here's what we believe about
x y and z
they just show you those things
happening and say that those things are
normal
and if conservatives want to have any
shout out winning the culture award they
need to do the same thing with the media
there's this tape from uh like the nixon
tapes uh and he's talking to some of his
advisors
um you can find this online and he's
like turning to i can't remember who it
is
but he's like you see on the tv they're
making the working man look stupid like
an
oaf and the or the urban homosexual
they're making them look cool
[Laughter]
i don't i don't think it's i don't think
it's but i think there's true like
fathers are always depicted as complete
idiots
absolutely the real housewives if you
watch that show which you probably do um
do you no i'm just kidding um i have
been lately a little bit as like a kind
of a social experiment but they're
they're alcoholics i mean they're pretty
much awesome
and i saw sheamus he had a tv and stop
tim you promised
it's subversive because they're all
alcoholics most of them but they don't
talk about it really they just laugh and
joke about it and they have like funny
music going on and she's taking her like
fifth shot
and you know what the point of those
shows are is to have your average person
watch it and say well i'm not
that bad so i really don't need to
improve hold on you know what i i
we we talk about when everything went
bad and everyone says harambe is a joke
but maybe you know we used to have tv
shows that were like family-friendly
wholesome
shows about like moral messages about
improving yourself and being better
we had superheroes yeah and then all of
a sudden it became about dysfunction
something happened and then whose fault
is it is the boomers can we blame them
are they the ones that are lsd
it's easy to blame someone else for our
problems right there are ways also to
portray dysfunction and even portrayed
as function in a comical way that
doesn't
glamorize it like looney tunes
that's a coyote is obviously an idiot
like animation is great for that oh
i mean okay maybe i went too far his
devices keep failing yeah it's not just
acne's fault but he is dumb for not just
going
yeah back me and being like hey guys i
want a refund can i get is there a
different company why is he still
choosing this brand they must have
phenomenal customer service because none
of their products work
acme's like if you want to build your
own dynamites go ahead you want to build
your own acme
dude i'm pretty sure oh my gosh was this
wiley coyote and roadrunner a cautionary
tale about monopolies
yes what happens when corporations take
over there's acme
actually does that stand for something
there's actually a uh
a family guy joke where he's going to
get a refund and his wife's yelling at
him
he's like he's in the store and he's
like look it didn't work i paid for this
and like nothing he ever bought worked
well to be fair also roadrunner had
magic powers like when wiley would draw
the fake
tunnel on the wall in the room would
actually run through it and then he
wouldn't maybe
roadrunner was part of his imagination
and he was tripping was that like the
50s or the 60s cautionary tale for
not taking your medication also not
allowing large corporations to
dominate an entire market okay dominate
the market what if they have a giant
cartoonish magnet what if they're
rockets
what if there was a law that said if you
were diagnosed with a mental uh illness
you couldn't vote
oh that's dangerous yeah because also
dissent is so frequently pathologized
even now if you disagree with the
homosexual lifestyle you're a homophobe
you have a phobia
you're a transgender you're a critic of
islam you're you're in an islamophobe
you're an islam
yeah we were talking about no one gets
to vote nobody nobody no votes i'm
finally
gone only one person gets to vote this
time pope francis it's the robot
what if we just had a lottery every year
and one person it was like a handful
maybe like 12 people
denmark i think it was um that's what
it's called i think it was
buckley who said he would rather be
governed by the first hundred name in
the phone book the first hundred names
in the phone book than
the committee at harvard and the
oligarchy
i mean the problem is it would be like
it would be like john
you know anderson bill aardvark and it's
like people be changing their names bro
yeah i'd call myself uh uh
i'd be the president 100 random names in
the phone book tim all right problem
solved
and everyone's trying to get in the
phone book yeah yeah
there's no phone book anymore they're
they're not real actually they like
the latest page they're online they're
online they're online do you guys think
there's a peaceful
like um i don't know if there's a
solution is the right word but
transition
kind of because it seems like our free
speech has gone so far
out of whack that we're allowing things
that maybe shouldn't be allowed ah
that's not what i want to say
well no i mean i want to say you said it
then you're like ah what is wrong
i'm going to be emperor here and say
good
i want to say this though i i think
there is something they flow through you
there is something really interesting to
be said about this though because you
just said something
oh i don't want to say that i mean
you're exploring your thoughts here
and when you make a public statement
you're sort of connected to it for the
rest of your life even if two seconds
later you disagree with what you just
said it's a very strange phenomenon i
mean
i understand the necessity to be
responsible when you're speaking in
front of thousands of people
i'm not discounting that but at the same
time this conversation is occurring
live and in the back of our minds
there's this question of
am i going to say the right thing am i
going to trip up and am i going to be
irresponsible it's it's something you
can't remove from the equation no matter
how hard you try i think that's really
interesting
because it's not examined enough when
people watch live shows that have other
people talking about that
that's why i'm fundamentally a writer
like i write because
you can try and refine edit yeah exactly
these formats i only do when i'm
promoting a book
exactly and we spend our entire lives
practicing conversation
totally in private and the skill sets
for a private conversation don't
necessarily map onto a public
conversation because you don't know how
your audience is going to understand you
the way you do the person
sitting across from you will yeah that's
true i try and i try and make a fool of
myself that way so that other people
aren't don't get hit by it because
you're right so i want to get out ahead
of that so then do we adopt
authoritarian classical liberalism where
what we do is
we anybody who who's uh who's advocate
using free speech to advocate for
anti-uh liberalist values is
is is uh figuratively crushed the
descent is is removed
only the code that's sort of
that's what brought us here that's right
so i got to say
real quick that's like james pointless
the left is literally advocating for
that
not tolerating intolerance saying we're
very tolerant of everyone except for
those who oppose
us but then you see like last year when
they were
burning buildings and things and and
nothing happened like there wasn't uh a
federal
national guard response like did we let
it get go too far did we leave
freedom no no there was a national guard
response but it wasn't very much and it
didn't stop the riots
it wasn't a national guard response as
in like they went and started arresting
people right
it was actually that the national guard
shut up stood around and then they still
ride it anyway
yeah so like what do we do do we do we
crack down on like rioting and
absolutely of course yeah i mean rioting
is is illegal and so it just means a mat
but but
the way i i i think i think not i mean
kamal harris raised money to get them
out of jail and they did and their
charges were dropped
no no i'm saying it's not being enforced
or it's being selected selectively
enforced
so um that just goes to show that none
of these categories
is neutral all right so my long-term
solution is is
taking uh i got i got an idea
of the universe is
conservative but a conservative who
believes that
we we do need a government to
to mediate between these different
actors in society
and and and to you know authoritatively
guide people to virtue so
you know friends in in britain who call
themselves fascists that's horrible
because fascism is
is more kind of raw exercise of power
yes
and tyrannical i'm not not friends of
mine in fashion
sorry sorry yeah the sort of the people
you met at the rally but
but i think a government that
authoritatively guides people to to be a
little bit more virtuous through policy
and so forth that's that's just what the
purpose of govern
government is you know we're one way or
another we're guided to some morality
yeah i certainly want to do it and i
have the solution it's really obvious
been in front of us the whole time
what's that you see these these these
leftists have been infiltrating our
cultural institutions
and our government the right just needs
to all start showing up to antifa
meetings and then gain positions of
authority within antifa
infiltrate and then when all of these
different local antifa chapters are run
by modern conservatives
then that's it no more anti-fun no more
rioting boom done
reversal filtration i think uh with what
you're saying
i hear you and i don't ultimately think
that that's big government there are
different approaches to it some would
involve more government involvement than
others and
i also just want to echo what you you
said about fascism
it's very unfortunate it's just this
strange totalitarian marxism larping is
traditionalism
ultimately i believe that a country as
large as the united states especially
with a government as big as ours is
fundamentally impossible
i don't think it's going to last in the
long run i think the kind of social and
cultural decay we're seeing is probably
going to continue
ideally we would have states with much
more autonomy to implement the kind of
i think in those individual states
virtue based governing strategies
because what you try to implement now in
a place like georgia
probably isn't going to fly somewhere
like california but the problem is the
nation is so
tightly interlinked because of how
massive our federal government is
that everyone is invested in what's
going on in states that they might not
even visit in their lifetimes
so i would say we really need to roll
back the power of
federal government and so in that way
i'm very annoying they won't believe you
they won't leave you alone in your like
red state readout
they will because that's the nature of
the ideology i also think that's game is
a
federal game and it'll it'll be played
on that field so you have to
i just you think so i see i think it's
possible that at some point the federal
government will become
incredibly weakened uh i don't see it
happening in the immediate future
uh and again maybe this is just wishful
thinking on my part because i agree with
you that if you have the federal
government
especially with the power that it has
people on the left are never going to be
able to tolerate the existence of a
right-wing
society they just won't and even if you
have
so it's complicated i mean there is
something about unvirtuous people who
are living on virtuous lifestyles where
they they cannot tolerate the existence
of people
whose existence challenges their
conscience fundamentally
so i hear you there but i also
i don't want to slide into this thinking
where where uh we reject any and all use
of power but
i just don't see a lot of these
right-wing strategies working
effectively
at the federal level in terms of
development of virtue
so look you have to have you have to
have uh
private exhortation to virtue people
have to yeah you know uh
family matters and so on and so forth
but at the bottom line is i
i think i think we're in a really really
bad state like we're in
a kind of dystopia it feels like i mean
there's a kind of
twitter joke and we laugh about it but
it kind of feels real it's like you know
eat the cicadas
eat the bugs live in the pods look at
the porn live in your pod and have like
your food delivered by
drone and and increasingly your face
mask so you don't have any
in but this is this is the stuff of like
blade runner movies or
whatever and except it's becoming real
so to me
that takes dramatic action but the good
thing is um
uh you know you you precisely because of
the nature of
of power if of power as it exists now
if you infiltrate it you can very
quickly
uh reshape society i think because the
law is a teacher
what the law approves what it
authoritates people will
and and you you'd be surpri i really
believe this you'd be surprised how
quickly people will change their minds
and then they will forget that a week
earlier they held the contrary your
opinion
so you have to as power shifts they're
like oh yeah i've always been here
you know so so for me what that means is
for conservatives you know they often
say well we don't have the culture with
us
what does that mean like you know the
vast middle of people go this way and
that
what really matters is if you could
capture the elite
as an elite you know into positions of
power
you can very quickly shift the ship of
state as it were
i think that's interesting i'm
definitely going to really strongly
consider that
my point has more or less been that i
think the united states government
is just too gigantic and this is too
large a country to be governed under one
main governing body
i mean you seem to be saying something
different and i do really want to
consider that so i'm open-minded here
what would you think
i would ask well no i guess i guess my
point is
when you have 50 states and initially
when the united states was set up it
wasn't intended to be a country where
you have this monolithic federal
government
running this gigantic country it was
more or less smaller states governing
themselves and then the federal
government could come in and
regulate trade or dictate a common
currency solve other disputes
ensure that the constitution is being
held to but
now it's as if people almost go directly
to the federal government whenever they
want a law changed instead of looking at
how they can implement change on the
local level
and i just i fear that it becomes a
possibility for me 130 million to be
guaranteed by the same we have a
national economy we have an
international economy and therefore
localism doesn't really doesn't really
work
it's just the nature of the of the thing
and i think you know
at least certainly the kind of
hamiltonian strand of the founding
is not quite as you describe it it's
more like energy in the executive
is constantly the president so um
yeah you know i mean they were not all
of one mind i'm always open to the idea
of
subsidiarity yes in catholic social
teaching which is that problems should
be solved at the level appropriate to
them so if a family
can solve a problem then the local
municipality shouldn't interfere
and if a local municipality can solve a
problem then like the state shouldn't
interfere
but i think we're at a point where all
the crises we're facing
unfortunately can't be solved at the
level of family local means but
it has to go all the way up that's
interesting global or national problems
so i hear what you're saying yeah and
this idea behind subsidiarity
it it goes as far as to state that the
most local possible authority
should be the one to solve it um but
then we have that conflicting with
solidarity as well i think over the past
hundred years
we have moved so much away from
subsidiarity and maybe that's what's
created this problem where
it's as if nothing can be solved at the
local level i have to consider that more
strongly as well
what would be like an example you think
of like um some
some way the federal government could
could could shift or change policy to
to enact what you're talking about like
a like a psychological shift in the
in the world sure let me know so like we
i think we should promote
uh people forming families and having
children yeah and so i would do what
like the polls and the hungarians are
doing which is
you know if you uh you know if you have
four
children or more you're exempt from
income tax for the rest of your life
or you get a cash subsidy even or or or
you get a loan for a van so people could
carry your
you know but so but that has to that
means that conservatives have to believe
that it's good for people to form
families and have children yeah
and for the government to spend and tax
it's been intense
like the heritage foundation types and
the entire apparatus
of the conservative movement is created
to give lip service to these kinds of
things
but then push uh policies that uh
deracinate people
that work really well for goldman sachs
and and and and
and basically financiers big
corporations
and not and they'll say they'll be
alarmed they'll be like oh if we do a
certain kind of policy where moms stay
home
more then moms won't enter the workforce
heaven forfeit
yeah kind of work you saw the concern
actually there's nothing there that was
heritage yeah yeah yeah yeah they were
like oh no i don't know
i would disagree with by the way we
should uh jump over to super chats
so if you haven't already give us a good
little like it's very simple if uh if
you think cnn deserves more views than
us then don't
don't press the like button don't share
the video then we can all just sit here
and be grateful that cnn is as big and
as powerful
and privileged as they are because you
know youtube puts them on the front page
they're the authoritative source isn't
that funny i mean think about a few
seconds
cnn was lying to us for years about
russia
and and youtube will still put them on
the front page as the authoritative
source
so in all serious seriousness if you
think that's a problem
you can share this show uh you can
become a member at timcast.com and just
know that your membership is going to go
towards hiring more journalists
reporters
and working on building up this newsroom
as well as a bunch of other shows of
course we do have the paranormal show
we've been working on
and a bunch of other fun stuff but uh
let's read some of your super chats
and uh we have here jason mcneill says
maxim bernier the only political leader
against lockdowns in canada has been
arrested in canada
getting more worrisome as time goes on
when they started locking down the uh
the country these states it was it was
despotism it was it was an act of
authoritarianism
and still you know most people just sit
back and say well you know i won't
violate my principles so
what ends up happening is these democrat
governors
keep doing it they're not going to stop
all right we got bryce uh blosser says
hoping we will have a better governor
next year in virginia in the meantime
check out blenderfarm.com for small
family farm a
small family farm american prime beef
for patriots
free shipping hey that's cool maybe
we'll go and check that out that's
awesome
blender farm chris h as i'm happy that
you seem to have fixed your internet
issues
it is deeply disappointing trying to
listen to your stream live at 2 am in
germany with connection issues
apologies for that um so apparently the
lightning strike fried one of the boxes
yes so that's why all the internets were
having the router was on fire
that's wild yeah so the lightning strike
hit the cable
where it's that's so weird oh no yeah
the kind of elevator it was it was
it was like some like some lightning
strike friday uh the line that went into
the box and it only damaged some of it
but
they had to replace the line that's cool
though you know
lightning yeah bug hq says a nc
steel machining place was hit by a cyber
attack today is steal the new target
shout out to jj the best step dad i
could hope for for my daughter
don't eat the bugs guys they're for the
lizards i should know
so we're trying to get we're trying to
do live events there's a bunch there's a
couple hurdles we have to overcome one
of them is
structural but we just had some guys be
like look we don't think you can do
steel because the prices are way too
high
to like open up the building and make it
better and
so i don't know they're like you have to
double up lumber it's cheaper but still
ridiculously expensive
so they went after the food the oil and
now the steel
yeah building equipment would all right
one eye gaming says ian a few days ago
you said you were worried about who
russia would side with if war broke out
between america and china yes
russia will either side against china or
stay neutral china claims russian cities
and competing with russia in arms sales
well remember how
staying neutral worked for the russians
in world war ii i guess technically they
sided with the germans and then they got
invaded by the germans so i don't know
if they're gonna make that same mistake
again with china
right on first last says can i still be
a christian without going to church
and liking the pope is reading the bible
hearing people like jp and cliff
nectal from youtube ask cliff a good way
for spiritu spirituality and one with
god
this is a really really good question
i'm sure saab has an answer for this as
well i would say that
jesus christ came to earth and he he
died for your sins and came back from
the dead and he founded a church
and through that church he has
delineated clear rules for the ways
a person must go about getting to heaven
and
one thing that we're bound to do is
attend mass every sunday
and so well you spoke about the pope and
you also spoke about
christianity without referencing
catholicism i assume you're probably
asking a question about catholicism
because of that invocation of the pope
and i would say one of the requirements
to be considered a practicing catholic
is to observe all the necessary holy
days which would
include the the sunday obligation to
attend math so i would say you should do
it and
i'm not sure if you're in an area which
is particularly locked down or if you've
been to a catholic mass before but i
would recommend going to your first if
you haven't and
talking to the the priest there and
asking him
some of these same questions and
furthermore if you can try to find a tlm
a traditional latin mass because i
promise if you do that priest will have
solid answers for you i got a question
for you guys about jesus do you think
that he
was the the meat body of jesus or
the spirit that inhabited his body he's
both both still does he this is actually
interesting isn't that arianism that he
was
he was a creation of god yeah yeah
exactly and so uh and it's
very gnostic movements in late antiquity
which basically said that
um you know what you are is this divine
spark that happens to be trapped yes in
a in a kind of fleshly apparatus that's
bad
um and you see it by the way echoed in
modern translations
i talked about that last week okay the
idea that
i'm just the kind of mental material
that's my real self and this body
means nothing therefore i can do
everything with it
orthodox historic christianity always
made a point of saying that that jesus
christ was fully man
and it had a soul true but also a true
god of truman but also had a body
he was you know he his mother bore him
to term just like any other person and
and therefore it's a kind of it resists
those gnostic tendencies
yeah so christianity especially in its
catholic iteration
is incredibly concerned with matter too
it's not just this kind of airy fairy
spiritual spirit the spirit is important
yeah but but we're human beings we're
embodied
and the fact that jesus is fully man
fully god um
therefore gives us a bodily heaven claim
on heaven not just the spiritual one
yeah that's very that's that's i mean i
couldn't have said it better myself and
i'll just add this this is part of why
it's so important
that christ rose from the dead body and
soul it wasn't a metaphorical
resurrection
he literally came back and as catholics
we believe in a resurrection of the dead
which means that we believe at the end
of time everyone will be resurrected and
given a body don't you think that
someone just robbed his grave and took
his body
well no because there were eyewitness
accounts of him being alive after the
crucifixion
after he'd already been buried let's uh
this is good
good stuff i'll fight you naked says
thanks tim i bought physical gold crypto
and survival food
i'm not a financial advisor lydia thanks
for taking the time to read my article
but mine takes six minutes to read and
someone with a following stole my title
and wrote some woke sympathetic bs
interesting i love you i fight you naked
i'll fight you naked i like that name
all right okay actually is it okay if
before the next super chat i asked sorb
a question
this this might this might take a little
too long and so if it's an after show
discussion i'd still be really
interested in that one thing we were
discussing was the fact that people who
live real and virtuous lifestyles and i
think it's especially
linked to unchastity have this
incapability of tolerating virtuous
societies
and so i'm curious about how that maps
on to any social change that
conservatives might
attempt to implement at the federal
level like you were discussing
is it possible are those people just
ungovernable at the federal level
i guess what what is to be done about it
i mean look i have to go to sort of
basics which is that um
you know saint thomas in the treatise on
law
relying on aristotle's ethics says that
um exhortations to virtue aren't enough
so the certain kind of you know there's
a kind of christian that says
just just privately do your thing yeah
evangelize the culture
that's not enough because uh the ruler
who wants to lead us
people to virtue needs to have the
ability to to
uh uh use authority right and kind of
lovingly
use authority so i think um the
the first thing i would want to see from
is just a society that makes it a little
bit easier
yeah to to start a family to have a
family and not to sort of be bombarded
with
um you know let's say pornography right
100 as you know with you as you know um
nine out of ten boys will see hardcore
porn
before hitting puberty that's the
university of new hampshire
that's a really bizarre society yeah
that's so
i i just want some of the sort of the
worst of it at least curved
and i just give space for people to
because we we are human beings we're
relational animals we thrive in families
we uh you know we we seek union with
with one other person
um all this stuff has been so distorted
yeah
that's the problem and as goes as they
say you know as goes sex so goes
the family so it goes to society and
we've allowed our sexual attitudes to be
completely distorted
like when you walk yeah that's a really
good answer i'm glad i asked it
all right lost in my head 60 63 says
freedom tunes brightens my day
oh thank you tim keep it the good work
you too lydia more dmt ian okay also can
you shout out no no ian no yes yes let's
go
my gofundme help us build an off-grid
community i lost my job to covet and
china after spending a long time
building
towards this goal sounds cool that is
very cool
all right mevro st john says a follow-up
to a super chat about world of warcraft
earlier this week
it's honestly funny to think about left
and right as alliance and horde they
hate each other so much they can't see
the things they share in common
uh very obviously the horde is the left
and the alliance is the right that's why
i like thrall because there are people
on the left
that that shake the shackles of of
slavery of mind
huh yeah the horde is is is the left for
sure the alliance is the right
thrall was like this orcish shaman that
was like just transcended orcism and
became like
unified with the humans and the elves
and just realized there was a greater
purpose to
fight the demons really i guess you
would say or or protect our the other
living organisms from the demons
all right cooler in tech says first time
super chats tim
i know a little hvac and am a
professional
liz simp oh wonderful you should hire me
so i can escape california
uh i don't think we need anybody for
hvac you know but uh
send an email to jobstimcast.com if
you're interested
all right samuel eddie says live in the
cabin eat the venison harvest the fields
and buy the guns
yes dude liberals read that and they're
like how horrible yeah we should make a
shirt that says that yeah yeah
and then uh we'll we'll make we haven't
we haven't eat the bugs
eat the bugs graphic it's a cornucopia
with bugs bursting from it
and i'm trying to figure out what the
right thing to do with it is it's hard i
don't know if
a shirt makes sense maybe we'll make the
shirt anyway it's you know
all right omg puppy says rods from god
if you are in orbit and drop something
it just orbits there next to you
if one ton rod hits at eight kilo
kilometers per second orbital speed
kinetic energy equals five tons of tnt
for nuclear size explosion you need 100
times that speed
but what if you shoot it down and then
that would that would hyper accelerate
the
the speed i would think i don't know
rather than just drop it
yeah perhaps they just lightly tap it
yeah
and then it starts accelerating faster
and faster and faster
just a little tap cackling kamala says i
worked at a liquor store in the 90s and
paid 20 bucks a month for insurance and
better coverage than i do now
conservatives think we can get back to
that i'm not so sure um
there's a there's a funny joke i saw
it's uh find a woman who enjoys laughing
as much as kamala harris loves laughing
when you ask her about human traffickers
smuggling children
yeah any questions she can't answer
hillary clinton too though what's up
with that dude that's so true did you
ever see that place-bowling music video
of hillary clinton's laugh
remixed it's perfect it's just called
hillary is evil you all need to james
james
ask me what my favorite color is what's
your favorite color tim
good man that's like that's how i
envisioned like all of these interviews
with kamala
my favorite my favorite was when like i
can't remember who it was like a pbs
woman was asking her serious question
and then she just sits there like with
her mouth and like smiling just like
eyes all wide like what are you doing
because she laughs the answer
and the journalist kept pressing like i
want an answer this she laughs
what's the answer and then she's just
like so i think i think the question was
about the fact that she had condemned
biden as a sexual
assault rapist and a racist yeah and
then she was like well what do you think
now that you're you're his running mate
and she just said she says it was a
debate
you said the man was a rapist who hates
black people it's like it was a debate
it was a debate you make things up when
you're debating people that's exactly
it though that's how horrible the
discourse is where it's it's considered
like a legitimate and fair debate tactic
to call someone a rapist and a racist
those are just those are just
accusations we throw around those
words there was also recently kamala was
asked about going down to the border and
she was like
i'm not going to go to europe either i
was like what what are you talking about
that wasn't even
analogous
all right derek lozano says great show
tonight guys i'm a 30 year old father of
three and i'm also the mailman for my
neighborhood
i've tried to get to know all of my
customers over this past year talk to
your neighbors people are hurting that's
awesome that's right yeah it's good for
you
i like that i like that michael johnson
says hey tim and company big fan of the
show
did you hear the rcmp just arrested max
and bernier in manitoba
he's one of the only canadian
politicians who has spoken out against
the harsh lockdowns we have up here
villa frey posted about it he's great i
love him man canada
who'd have thought they'd go full
fashion man i know i could have
predicted that i mean canada's had hate
speech laws which have made
quoting scripture an offense i i will
say that my entire bible study full of
lovely sweet canadian ladies is
literally all ready to move to the u.s
like florida and vermont yeah i've
talked to other canadians too or like i
am done with this country i'm like good
for you yeah
we've got we got okay corlex he says hey
tim i have been watching your videos
and show for a full year now i'm happy
for you luke was one of my favorite
people on here and i miss him
however sheamus is a great replacement i
listen every day since august well i
have really good news
we are are evicting sheamus and luke is
coming back that's right
also to be fair so i wouldn't see myself
as a replacement me being on here has
had nothing to do with luke being gone
yeah it's not as if like luke left like
sheamus come on i've just been here
working with tim on some projects
and when i'm here we like to do yeah i
was voicing doctor fought yeah he was
voicing dr fauch we've been working on a
card game and some other really exciting
stuff
video game yeah and a video game so we
probably need more devs
if we really want to get the video game
what i'm what i'm looking for honestly
is is more help creating the sprite so
if there are animators we could find
who'd be willing to help who could
emulate my style decently that would be
a massive help and it would allow us to
get the game done pretty quickly i think
sure at least more quickly than our and
then on our current trajectory have we
talked about what the game was about yet
i don't know but not yet i don't know
how much we should tease it's going to
be real like
how about just like chris and i were
playing earlier today and it was the mo
we were playing the multiplayer mode
he's been putting together it was so
much fun
it it looks like it's really great i
mean i'm really happy with how it's
shaped up
let's not say the name yeah but i'll
give a basic description without going
into details
you just all right does that work i
don't know you know what i shouldn't say
anything i think i think we should be
really careful about this
all i will say is this i when i was
first the idea was first described to me
i thought it was very interesting i was
like yeah this is something i would
definitely want to
collaborate on and supply my my style to
and as i have been helping to develop
these sprites and seeing how the game is
is shaping up i'm very pleased
it's going gonna be amazing if um
animators get in touch with you what's
the best way for them to get in touch
with that's a good question so since
it's for this game
uh i don't have a i don't have an email
address created for
soliciting workers they usually reach
out other ways if someone's interested
in working on this game as an animator
can we just have them send an email to
jobs at tim cast yeah would that work
for you
yeah put video game animation yeah just
put like video game animator in the
subject line uh send an email to jobs at
tim cast
and video game developer needing help
yeah all right let's see
we've got uh i can't read cyrillic so
i'll just try and pronounce it as if
it's not cyrillic that's a long name
ebrahen eric
that's a that's not even an a pop uh i
can't read surly
hey carl popper was amazing man his
criterion of empirical false
falsifiability is the foundation of
modern science real science not to trust
the science of macabre
i look up schwab how do you feel about
that i think he was a midwife
all right no not not in my cup of tea
okay but fair enough i mean
he was an important thinker alpha twitch
he says hey tim i'm buzzed so here's an
anime recommendation
watch vivi the fluorite eyes song
all right diego salazar says careful how
you decide what is decent and what's not
times change and society oscillates like
a pendulum one side makes more force
towards them
the more extreme it will be when it goes
back and vice versa
balance is the only answer like i think
about the aztecs and they would instead
of kill their opponents in battle
knock them unconscious and to drag them
back to t
cut their chests open and and like
people still thought that was horrible
in the aztec the aztecs a lot of them
still thought it was so maybe there is
like moral absolutism i don't know
yeah for sure there's an objective moral
order yeah the fact that
you're interiorly aware that something's
wrong suggests there is an objective
moral order
which means that that there is decency
and indecency in
every any given age and across time and
across civilizations
amen sheamus yes you ready for this one
i am
murray fairy says third super chat
attempt anyone know
if sheamus is single asking for a friend
she's 23
catholic and single that's very sweet i
am single oh
look at that sheamus just basically said
i would like to meet this one and if
they would like to contact you do you
have an email now
jobs
i would like to apply for a job being
shame as his wife i'm a 45 year old man
looking for work mad cow says
it was not an insurrection or riot it
was a peaceful protest just to be clear
not being sarcastic i think we should
start referring to as january 6 as a
mostly peaceful protest yes
oh i looked up the definition of
insurrection it was basically yes what
antifa did last year was an insurrection
right yep
it was a draft definition of
insurrection is a violent uprising
against an authority or government check
check check
okay because the it was against the
authority then yeah it was it was
insurrect oh no the couch says hey tim
long time listener first super chat
wanted to see if anyone saw the
cringe-worthy segment they did with
jeffrey toobin
how does someone get caught doing what
he did and keep their job
who is that guy that's like a story it's
like he said boobs on cnn so they banned
him
what yeah like he was i can't remember
who this was they were like i went on
cnn and said boobs and they kicked me
off but
jeffrey toobin gets caught you know
sounds like a bunch of boobs
doing it on camera with one of his
employees co-workers
tube in his own horn oh that was our
headline at the post for that
so tube is a verb right now tube two
yeah two minutes
yeah tuban is when you are on a work
call with a bunch of other colleagues
and they're watching through your webcam
guys there are good 23 year old catholic
girls watching
all right all right all right let's see
we got here
name and fame says please read i've
super chatted this on multiple videos
beef is not bad for the environment look
up eating less meat won't save the
planet here's why
by what i've learned he debunks all the
climate arguments and links sources
so why won't they let us eat beef
they're rude why is joe by like come on
because he doesn't like one cheeseburger
a year he doesn't like the po boys
it's like some dude got bit by one of
those ticks that makes you allergic to
beef
yeah a friend of mine claims that that
happened why am i saying claimed we all
make fun of him we're like that's not
true you're lying
but he got like bit by this take a while
ago and he is allergic to basically
everything he can't eat meat anymore
yeah so so it's like it's like the
origin story for a villain
it's like he just it's this guy he's a
griller he's just like all day flipping
burgers and smiling and waving he's
really good at it everyone loves him and
then one day the tick bites him
and then he's like no and then he takes
the burger he bites it and he swells up
if i can't have it no one can and then
he
starts an organization called pita or
whatever
that's hilarious that's very good no one
should be allowed to have beef well
here's the thing i'm actually a person
for the ethical treatment of animals
because i think it's perfectly ethical
to eat them
anything wrong with that yeah that's a
good point i am treating them ethically
by consuming them i believe it is
perfectly ethical we have dominion over
them as humans
the perfectly ethical treatment of
animals yeah or pita
pita i guess the of could fall off
people eating the animals
[Laughter]
people eating tasty animals
all right all right insert name here
says tim don't play their game calling
the riders as they want antifa
protesters if they're burning buildings
attacking people police fed
they are insurrectionists same as
politicians aiding and cheering them on
yep agreed literally that's a problem i
had with trump calling referring to the
left
as soon as he said it i felt like a
radical left yeah
he felt like he like he became a pawn in
the game like he fell for it
there is no left there is no right it's
all like just fake i agree it's
immediate i disagree no i mean there's
there's there's simplification of saying
the left and the right to
for colloquial reason but the actual
core of the definitions make little
sense outside of tribal signifiers
like what is what does left mean what is
left me
well again this is going back to my and
this is the definition i usually use
just
in its it's very broad and it may be a
little imperfect but just uh the purpose
of the left is to oppose the catholic
church and its goals and
gender what what what about democrat
voters who are like catholic
like joe biden no i mean you can't but
like you cannot vote for a pro-choice
candidate if there's a pro-life
candidate available as a catholic so
when people say that they're they're
pro-life democrats that is there's a
huge revolt
most americans do not agree with the
radical the radical left
the radical left on abortion no i agree
that it's amorphous but i also don't
want to fall into this trap of saying it
doesn't mean anything because it is a
very helpful term for identifying
enemies don't you think as a catholic
that if there was someone that is
espoused all
that actually exuded all the virtues
except they were pro-choice that they
would be a better candidate than someone
that's just
rife with with sin but was pro-life no
because i don't know how you could exude
all the virtues and be pro-choice from
being entirely honest yeah boom
well like six of the seven virtues or
whatever that's not enough
it's like dude hold on but if you
haven't figured out like don't kill
babies i don't know how much good the
other virgins are doing
seems basic but i didn't steal anything
oh yeah exactly i didn't steal
i wasn't lustful i wasn't yeah but you
didn't
all right let's see we got uh josie
pussycat says hey tim i replied to one
of your tweets with let's burn her at
the stake it was obviously a joke and
twitter suspended me thanks tim they
don't blame me
thanks a lot tim it's all tim's fault it
is yes
wait what is this napalm boner fart
great name by the way it's like a
napoleon thing yes napalm
says from the daily mail aoc's
grandmother came out in support of
donald trump
says he sent aid but puerto rico's
government did not use the aid why
really matt walsh sent aid to
as well that was really pathetic of aoc
did not take it
how am i i just thought it would have
been so amazing if she was like oh no
you you owned the libs thanks for
helping the poor people of puerto rico
and then it could have been like you
know what she could have done she could
have said
all right i'm gonna take this money and
you know what i'm gonna do we're gonna
use what we need to for the repairs and
donate
all of the rest to another gofundme and
the left is gonna prove we can raise
more money than the right to help the
people of puerto rico
how amazing that would have been and
then you get all the conservatives being
like come on guys
we got to raise money for the people
whose lives were destroyed by the
hurricane then the left
and then the left and the right raised
like 10 million each and then the poor
people of puerto rico
have their homes fixed i i like matt
walsh
and we're friends on twitter but i have
to say i i agreed with the uh
the she's she's a great account amy
therese i don't know if you guys follow
her no
but she she said uh you know like oh wow
you really owned her by raising you know
whatever like
yeah tens of thousands but aoc should
have turned it turned it into a uh
a woke off or a politics off or whatever
at some point
i think people need to not stop taking
it as seriously or at least
find a little levity and joy in life and
and the other
you know people that you think maybe
aren't your friends maybe are i think
that concept of joy as you're talking
about it
is is suprem is white supremacy
ben macklin says i'd love to see carl
from in-range tv on the show
he has a firearms and cyber security
background and made the news a while
back for putting firearms content on um
adulthub to show that he that the info
will exist somewhere i remember that
yeah uh yeah definitely sounds cool dude
sounds like a cool dude for sure
uh crandall logan says do the fouchy
voice of you diving out the window
was that ad-libbed um or did you tell me
i think i
might i i'd have to double check the
footage which people can see if they
donate at patreon.com i just went like
this i went dropping
pulled the mic away from droplets
droplets
you don't need to wear 12 masks if
you've been vaccinated 300 times
that's a joke obviously youtube's
already like i'm going to push the
button
oh don't push it no it's like the cdc
says
you know the meme where it's like i
don't know what the guy is but he's like
holding his hand and
the beams are coming out of it he's like
i must must ban
channel he made joke back to fouchy
i almost bought you a fouchy bobblehead
dude i can't bring myself to spend money
on
i'm so excited for him to disappear our
national life
all right all right we've got uh mr toad
says those that are anti-colonial and
want decolonization of institutions are
the same people that want
globalization open borders and call
themselves citizens of the world
they want a globally homogeneous
identity they want to colonize the
planet isn't that funny how that works
absolutely that's right i mean and they
and they want to basically
turn africa into a place where
contraceptives lgbt
bingo that is the most kind of
ideological in fact pope francis has
called that ideological colony colin is
that [ __ ] yeah that's right he did
wouldn't that result in like the birth
rate dropping dramatically in africa
yeah yeah they're fine with that they're
missing henry kissinger make a bunch of
really insane comments about the
population of africa
yeah and the gates the gates well they
they're i guess they're not a couple
anymore but they spend a lot of money on
ensuring that you know there are fewer
black babies born isn't that a little
weird
yeah it's not a little weird yeah i mean
but this is another thing the left
for as vague as these terms have become
the left is generally misanthropic they
don't want more people
and it's often disguised as
environmentalism yep
all right let's see
uh call me uh okay rondo says thanks for
all you do
bought some ethereum because of you no
regrets if the stock market crashes what
would be the best thing to do i cannot
give anyone any advice
um i don't know i got a bunch of
chickens we're getting a rooster
tomorrow
so i i posted that one of our chickens
is transgender
and it's true that it's not even i'm not
even joking it's a normal thing that
happens when there's no rooster
i think one in ten thousand they say
hens will start
appearing like a rooster and crowing and
acting like a rooster
but a lot of people informed me that
alpha hens
who become like roosters
are way more aggressive and could
actually end up killing
one of the other hands they're like you
need to get a rooster otherwise
that alphahen will seriously injure and
you need like so we got to bring a dude
in to kind of level things up the
scientists call them
uh karen's i knew i don't know it's a
really it's a it's a really interesting
thing because we would we
we we had to call the fire department
and it came out it's like three in the
morning and then all of a sudden i hear
and i'm like what was this and i look
over and
there's one like there's this chicken
and she's just like staring at me and
i'm like
staring back at her like what's going on
and then nothing happens i turn around
and then
again and then i turn around and there
she is but there's like other chickens
there i'm like was it
was that her and then all of a sudden
she's just looking me in the eye and she
goes
i'm like oh what are you doing you're
not a rooster and so then i looked into
it
today in the storm she was oh
wow and so i tweeted about it and people
were like you need to get a rooster
because if she starts doing that she
might actually kill
it's a crazy dynamic that they're like
you need to bring a man in
you need to bring in the male rooster it
seems like uh it seems like
like fallout centric white supremacist
patriarchal oriented science came up
with that
or nature no no but i was reading a lot
it said if you introduce a rooster into
the pecking order she'll stop doing that
and revert back to being
oh that's awesome yeah i guess they say
like sometimes the hen will be nominated
to be their protector
and like will take on the the job of a
rooster but in the meanwhile you're
going to refer to this hand with
the right pronouns yeah yeah well the
the thing is this this chicken's name
has always been
roberta beaks uh bobby beaks but now we
just say robert
bobby's bob robert but she hasn't
formally requested a change in pronouns
i'm glad you can stay on twitter i'm not
going to assume
chicken's gender but uh you know these
things very progressive things happen
yeah
so tomorrow uh again if you haven't
already go to youtube.comcastcastle
and subscribe because we'll have a video
up tomorrow it's fps cicada hunting
where i have this little like it's like
a nerf gun basically
and it's like it fires salt which knocks
skaters out of the air
it doesn't actually hurt them it's kind
of a weird thing i'm like worried about
hurting cicadas that i literally hunt to
feed the chickens
but it really doesn't you like bop them
and then they just kind of flutter down
and then you pick them up and give them
the chickens
chickens eat them yeah yeah i'm like
does that matter though it's chicken
food
it's like there's bug oh the cicadas are
basically gone now i don't know if you
guys have noticed interesting
rain no no no no no uh the the noise has
levels has dropped dramatically
and the cicadas that we're seeing are
tiny they're yeah they set up a quarter
of the size they only came out for about
two weeks is what i was going to be
was being told they come out for about
two weeks every seventeen people were
saying four to six well okay
but yeah we had it was really bad for
like one week
and these massive cicadas were
everywhere dude it was
nice did you see the guy posted a
picture on twitter of a cicada with a
white puff coming out of a spot yeah i
think it was the [ __ ]
fungus fungus i'm worried about it crazy
it's like a metal
amphetamine and there's it's a sign of
divine disfavor for the bible
that's right jonathan dugger says ac is
blue
and thus the left the alliance horde is
red and thus the right that's not true
if you take a look at world of warcraft
it's very obviously divided between left
and right
think about it the horde if those are
not familiar with world of warcraft
there's two facts there's two alliances
there's two factions one is called the
alliance one is called the horde
the alliance is like the realms of men
dwarves and elves essentially is a
complicated warcraft's history
but uh basically they're like beautiful
castles and
like european art styles
and then you look at the horde and it is
a bunch of marginalized and disaffected
communities
with who've like lost their homes who
band together
and it's also the craziest thing about
it is like
how overtly racist uh world of warcraft
is for instance
trolls all have jamaican accents
and they and they practice some kind of
voodoo magic the pandas have like the
asian accents yeah the pandas really
racist do kung
fu it's like super racist so i
i only played the like the first
warcraft which was a it's like a
dos-based game
oh yeah and it was only humans and orcs
and that was it it was it kept it simple
i
preferred that the orcs were fleeing
like their homeland which had been
attacked or taken over by like the
burning legion or something and so
they're going to
take over the earth or our domain as a
roth
refugees daniel mikkel says i watched
the quarterings lives remote 20 minutes
ago
someone said they won a contest you
offered and didn't get the skateboard
prize yet
uh that was probably a long time ago
adam was running those skateboard uh
prize contests so i'm not sure exactly
what happened with all that
last year yeah that was last year one
skateboard that was supposed to go
overseas that took us a lot of trouble
to get it going to the right place so
that might have been it everything else
i uh i wasn't uh i don't know
you know i guess maybe maybe something
fell apart apologies if that's the case
all right we'll just read this uh this
last one here
actually wait what's this okay yeah
we'll do one more bh says abolish the
federal government and make each state
its own country
yeah done like europe all right
everybody sort of what i was voicing my
opinion in favor of earlier
it's friday night we got some cold pizza
in the fridge
i got some hearthstone to play so make
sure you follow us on facebook and
instagram at tim cast irl if you're on
facebook you can like the page and then
help share our videos
to get more people to watch but i got to
tell you i am so incredibly excited
for the launch of this newsroom because
at a certain point
it just can't be me doing youtube videos
it's got to be more than that
and that means we need articles to be
written we need real investigative
reporting and we need to start building
a business that will survive
long after i have departed this world
and
i gotta say i was very much inspired by
uh by breitbart
breitbart.com uh andrew andrew breitbart
was one of the
most uh i was thinking about this james
o'keefe
why is he such a fighter why is he the
tip of the spear you know why is why
does he
is he is he working harder than anybody
else to challenge the
the corrupt and i'm like well one of his
big inspirations was
andrew breitbart and then i look at i
started thinking about where all these
other conservatives and not even
conservatives but you know anti-woke
personalities to start producing content
and try and grow a business and just
fight and fight and fight
and then i was like man andrew breitbart
really did that yeah they made all these
different sites
they're called breitbart.com they exist
today they've been extremely influential
they helped get a president elected
and i'm like we got to build something
so that uh you know rest in peace
andrew breitbart yeah uh long after i'm
departed the world and
you know there's something else that
will be powerful and big and will help
shine a light in the darkness are you
telling us you're going to go to mars
yes that's what i'm hearing you were
chosen elon called me and he was like
tim we have to go to mars
he's like starling didn't work but you
know it will we have to go to mars
tomorrow
it's the only way and i'm like yes
anyway uh so so follow us on facebook
and instagram look really not big fans
of them but we put up clips different
clips smaller clips
and you can share them because they're
nice little snippets from the show
and uh help people learn about the show
then go to timcast.com become a member
can't wait for this newsroom to launch
and we'll start having articles being
being put out there
we're going to do guest op-eds we're
going to have journalists in the field
in like the middle east and stuff we are
going and we're going to pay well we are
going to make sure journalists who are
doing
real journalism are compensated why i
want to create
market pressure for these news
organizations that produce garbage out
of new york city
to have those journalists be like it is
not worth my time
to write listicles about brad pitt's
junk when i can actually get paid the
same rate
for one article about say middle eastern
conflict yes
incentivize something better through the
market
build something better we're doing it so
uh again you can follow me personally at
timcast and uh do you want to mention
anything sir
sure saurabh amari at saraba mari
s o h r a b a h m like mary a
r i and the book is the unbroken thread
that's really great
i'm ian crossland and when you hey if
you guys want to support the channel of
course subscribe to the channel hit the
bell button next to it you'll see it'll
say
with your notifications none
personalized and all
make sure you set it to all that way
you're going to get notified
hopefully when the videos go up so
thanks for coming see you next time
yeah thank you guys for watching uh i'm
seamus coughlin of freedom tunes check
freedom tunes out youtube.com
freedom tunes we upload a cartoon once a
week usually twice a week i think you
guys will really enjoy them
do we got the next one coming out next
week there should oh my goodness no that
one
is in the works tim and i improv we
mentioned this in the last show we
improved the video
and it was really pretty good um i'm
thinking maybe
the week after yeah that's that's what
i'm trying to figure out because we we
sat here in rift for
how long maybe like 10 20 minutes 20
minutes yeah and so there's a lot of
material to pull out of it i'm trying to
get the best but i'm not sure how long
it's going to make it a two-parter
give it a cliffhanger it's got to be
it's it's got to be one two part
it's like it's like it's one continuous
narrative but we kept throwing jokes at
it
yes yeah looking forward to it yeah me
too super good yeah yeah
i am sour patch lids you guys can follow
me on twitter
i want to say as you're going into this
weekend that you guys need to notice
that the left
always projects when they talk about
normalizing things
yeah that's what they've been doing all
along they have control of all our tv
all our movies all our theater
everything that's entertaining to us and
they make
all of their ideas normal we need to do
that too
you guys follow me on twitter sarah
patrick's thanks for
hanging out everybody become a member at
timcast.com and go to
youtube.comcastcastle
and check out the vlog tomorrow at 9 00
a.m where uh
it's just silly fun and i take we we
mount a gopro on this little nerf gun
and i go around hunting cicadas
and thanks for hanging out we'll see you
all we'll see y'all next time
you